[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome welcome everyone this is the
speed chess championship finals going
down here with Carlson and Nakamura
the bullet portion comes to an end in
car Nakamura is mathematically
eliminated in his chances and the bottom
line is Magnus Carlson shows why he is
the Magnus Carlsen
it has been hikaru's speech test
championship this 2018 and Wesley so had
an amazing event this year as well and
we were tied heading into bullet before
akaranakamura separated himself in the
final portion
the blunders is rook and it's just
things are just not going well for
Wesley they traded back and forth
Landing heavy blows but ultimately the
heavyweight matchup is going to go
towards akaranakamura's favor
hey Cara will be winning his third in a
row extremely impressive display once he
actually faced a deficit he has looked
like the best a car we've seen
[Music]
welcome ladies and gentlemen to the
speed Chess Championship today is the
day of the second semi-final I'm
Grandmaster Daniel meriditsky and it is
a pleasure to be bringing you the
semi-final with my good friend
International Master David Bruce David
good afternoon to you are you excited
for icaro versus ding absolutely
absolutely Daniel I was really excited
to get the call for this show here I was
like wait I'm gonna get to watch Hikaru
play Blitz okay yes wait didn't you have
somebody else you could have you could
have called for this somebody more
deserving but yeah I'll take it well I
think you're plenty deserving and he
speaking of Hikaru both ikara and ding
have gone a very difficult path to make
it to these semifinals Hikaru had a
difficult first round matchup against
Fiddler then he beat Anish giri and of
course uh dingleren scored some could
say an upset against Lavon aronian so
it's obviously going to be a very very
tall order for dingler and today David
Hikaru needs no introduction over the
years and decades he's built a name for
himself as one could say the Undisputed
king of online Blitz chess and he's
going to try to maintain that today yeah
and uh as uh chess.com's lead
commentator now congratulations Dania
thank you
um I imagine that that you've seen quite
a few Hikaru matches but you haven't
seen him lose yet
I don't I don't believe I have and
yesterday he won yet another tournament
the arena Kings uh and it wasn't even
close so he's confident as ever and they
will be playing for quite some prizes
six thousand dollars
in the semi-finals to the winner and six
thousand more divided by win percentage
so there's a lot on the line but for
Hikaru I think it's safe to say he's
looking for that finals trophy he's
looking to win the speed chess
championship for the fourth out of five
times
we're gonna see if dangly Ren has it in
himself to score an upset and stop him
we're gonna go on our traditional short
break as the players get set up when we
come back the speed Chess Championship
second semi-final will kick in
but before we do we want to remind you
where this all comes from who is our
main sponsor it is of course coinbase
whether you're looking to make your
first crypto purchase or you're an
experienced Trader coinbase has you
covered visit coinbase.com chess and get
five dollars in Bitcoin not five Bitcoin
unfortunately but five dollars in
Bitcoin which is still good when you
sign up and verify your purchase yeah
I'd misread that before but uh so we
hope a lot of people misread it um but
definitely sign up and thank you to
coinbase we will be back in just a few
minutes with the match
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is going to be a real-time
breakdown of Danny wrench's games all
time on chess.com uh that's cool
oh in the last month I am playing 83.12.
I'm less accurate than them in every
stage yeah man that that stains a little
you should okay do the more game review
okay yeah thanks a lot okay so Tuesday
sucks I gotta stop playing cats on
Tuesday oh it's because it's titled
Tuesday
look how many blunders there were back
in December 2020 and now December 2021
1600 don't look at this number
look at look at this number best let's
go to
uh tactics
mates
I probably need to work on these ones
yep every single Rook Fork that has
presented itself to me I have found no
one has a higher percentage of Rook
Forks than I do
that's correct these are literally the
night Forks that you I missed Knight D6
it you saw it just now what is wrong
with me I could have done here and then
taken this pawn and I'm winning because
my pawns get held together that's
probably the coolest part about this
feature like these positions against
pets
Rook there for rookie too
and if you play there's a vision one
oh my goodness I'm awful
I have been loving chess.com's new
insights feature I've spent way too much
time there and you should go
procrastinate there as well make sure to
check out chess.com
insights and let's look at some of the
players insights that I picked out for
today dingley run David perhaps this
will come as a paradox to some he's
obviously got less games overall but he
has a higher accuracy I think he can
take some Solace than that but Hikaru
those time scrambles and those long
games he's got 72 percent he's got quite
the edge over Ding and Hikaru wins
significantly more games when games are
in the smooth category which if you
think about it is also not very
surprising given how stable and
consistent Hikaru is and how good he is
in these boring equal positions at
creating chances yeah I mean I grew up
thinking of I mean grew up he was
younger than me but as I was getting
into the Chess World in in Cairo too I
always thought that one of his strongest
assets was just sort of like brilliant
calculation extremely fast forward
vision and stuff like that so it's like
it's really telling that he's become
such an endgame monster right that like
if the game's going long he's grinding
it out again and again
yeah and I think that's a lot of people
think of vicaro as a purely tactical
player but I say that every commentary
he is an incredible positional player
and he's almost rebranded himself uh and
of course he still sees tactics and no
question about that but uh he's a very
very strong technical player and of
course end games as well let's have a
look at the smarter chess match
predictions uh David I've had I've been
having a long-standing commentators Feud
with smarter tests I feel necessary to
to I don't know there's something about
it I always feel the need to disagree
you're competitive and you want to be
more good at something more about
something than every other person
I want to be smarter about it you've
also got your title of profit at stake
right so yeah exactly you want to find
your moment to be like well he's smarter
chess and I'm profit chess so this is
the one time though that I might have to
I have to say the Forbidden word agree
with the smarter test predictions which
is calling for for it to be close after
the five plus one and smarter just
really thinks that ikara will start
pulling win the three plus one and I
think that's
I wouldn't necessarily call that
unlikely I think probably the five plus
one is ding's biggest chance David to to
really get ahead because that's what
he's gonna have to do you can't have an
equal match going into the bullet with
the car you just can't right it's it's
it's really hard for me also to imagine
how someone beats hicaro in one of these
matches since it's been years since he's
lost one I think the last time he lost
an SEC match was uh probably before you
were streaming
um I think that's that's right about
when uh you know the the Treaty of
Appomattox was signed yeah yeah it's a
the fall of the Ottoman Empire happened
a couple days before your car lost his
last match and the thing is like even if
somebody has like a decent chance in 5-1
even if they like let's say beat him in
five one by one point it's not going to
be enough to hurt his confidence it's
like let's start you need to get off to
but it's also not enough like right
that's the start that's the mandatory
start but then there's eight more time
controls you have to beat them in uh and
that like I said that Adventist Midler
was leading by one point and with Hikaru
is so good at and I I say this often he
senses when he's not in the greatest
form and because he knows so many
different openings he can steer the game
into let's say more solid Waters uh or
he can you know he starts playing more
solidly taking less risks he adjusts so
well based on his his given form right
so we see the game kick off here with
Hikaru playing white and a symmetrical
grunfeld and when we originally designed
the idea of this speech has Championship
part of the point of having like a
longer more epic three-hour match was
that it was supposed to reward p people
who can adapt over the course of the
match that was part of the idea
um was not just to see who's like the
better Blitz player but like if you're
stuck in a room with someone for three
hours and you can slowly figure out
what's going your way what isn't going
your way which of their openings you've
got the best chance again that you could
somehow adapt and come out on top
gradually right
yeah and I'm I'm really interested to
see how the first few games are going to
go in his previous match against the
niche uh the first couple of games ended
in a drawki car was playing very
conservatively in the opening and
mentored the end of the five minute
portion you know it seemed like he
gained some confidence he got warmed up
and that's when he started pulling away
and I think something similar is
happening here Hikaru playing a very
sort of non-theoretical solid
symmetrical grunfeld yeah ding has this
Pawn on A4 which could be either a
blessing or a curse I mean at some point
any car could start hunting for it with
Bishop B5 yeah I would definitely be
inclined to suspect it of being a
problem that pawn and A4
um I don't see that many black pieces on
the queen side to support the space that
the pawn is grabbing there's sort of
more minor pieces on the king side
then as you point out Bishop B5 could
create problems pretty quickly at some
point here so
I guess on the other hand Black's got
control of these two squares so Knight
takes D2 Queen takes D2 Knight A5 comes
to mind
aiming for B3 but this isn't a very
serious threat why could just take the
bishop and then move the queen and here
you go I mean all these pawns start
getting really loose
yeah and I was even liking the idea of
playing Knight B5 Queen before for white
there just sort of oh yeah pieces into
the weak squares on the B file
um
and uh yeah what what do you think by
the way of hikaru's like schedule like I
was just thinking about it before the
match started I saw him playing title
Tuesday on Tuesday Arena Kings on
Wednesday speeches championships on
Thursday do you think that there's ever
any kind of fatigue factor for Hikaru as
far as like trying to bring out his best
performance day after day at this kind
of like you know fast time control
against other world-class opposition
yeah I mean one would think it is a
factor but then you actually see
hikaru's track record when he's got
these very busy segments and and
sometimes he'll even have you know an
actual rapid tournament like like part
of the Magna store for example and he'll
simultaneously play title Tuesday and
win it I then he'll do an eight-hour
stream the day after the tournament ends
uh where he's playing Blitz all all the
time so so it's almost like he's
impervious to it yeah overall you feel
like it seems like it should be a factor
but not really for now it I'm sure it is
you know no matter how much of a
superhuman you think you are you are
prone to fatigue even if subconsciously
as we see Hikaru declining a repetition
they had repeated the repeated moves
once with this Knight H4 Knight F3
but uh
I think it's extremely minimal for him
and he's so experienced he just knows
how to power through it
yeah I guess we'll see
I feel like right now he's kind of
feeling ding out with this first game
with like the repetition and all it's
like how fast are you going to repeat or
not repeat like just sort of gut start
gut checking the opponents so that you
can make whatever adjustments you want
to make over the course of the match
right and uh ikaro decided to play
Bishop D3 ding taking the Knight rather
than the bishop and I think that is out
of concern for the for the A4 pie just
didn't want to that night on c3i they're
jumping to B5 or attacking the pawn
but me I again I would say Hikaru is
probably marginally better uh thanks to
the the weakness of the Apon and yeah
ding you know two and a half minutes
against icaro it's so easy you know you
drop anywhere below one minute you're
basically busted
allowing G4
interesting we're playing guitar goes
for Something Completely else looking
for Queen F3
yeah dick has to be very very careful
about that Bishop on H3 I mean G4 is
definitely a threat now
yeah maybe G4 Bishop F6 but
okay I mean it's scary
yeah I mean and and the other thing
about playing F4 here is if black wanted
to play H5 to secure the bishop then
you're weakening G6 horribly and F4 is
really well poised for white to go after
that square correct but then going E6
and I guess the whole point is G4 is
going to be met with Bishop F6 and the
Knight can't drop back to F3 because you
lose the pawn so
yeah I wanted to play like Queen F3
Bishop H4 G5 and trap both Bishops
inside but black will pull the one out
on H3 right away that's really funny
yeah let me just show that yeah
something like
this kind of situation where you've got
them both trapped at the yeah you can't
trap one without letting the other one
go it's like the tall thing where you
can only take one piece at a time right
it's too bad your G Pawn Can Only Hold
one of them in at a time exactly so E6
by by dinky car contemplating his next
course of action yeah Queen F3
is definitely still possible G4 is still
possible
um maybe you can move the Knight back to
F3 yeah of course ding has kind of
nepoed his Bishop but
it cannot be easily trapped at the
moment in the car now down at two
minutes himself
yeah not easy to make a decision on this
one
very deep think
uh I don't see like a feeling move off
the top of my head there's G4 Place G4 I
guess ding's long-term plan was to bring
the bishop back to F5 and let the Knight
trade it and hope his Pawn structure
could keep the D3 Bishop at Bay even
that I would have thought would be like
a bit of an edge point
what is D4 what a move what's this well
takes takes I think I see his idea he
wants to trade I only stopped here I
said black doesn't have anything but he
hasn't been F2 so all of a sudden
mapping the Knight on H4 and wait a
second here why it's in huge trouble
Knight F3 obviously you get mated so
what Hikaru has to do I think is Bishop
takes D4 and then go after go after the
other Bishop after all I think he might
have to go for this position takes take
screen F3 but then ding's gonna start
taking a million pawns that's really
messy that's really messy because
there's nothing nice about White's
position there other than that you have
the extra piece but everything else is
kind of trashy and I was thinking this
morning before the match what does ding
have to do to give himself a realistic
chance
I know I'm sitting here you know sipping
on a drink criticizing 2800s but yeah I
think his tactical Vision particularly
sense of these one or two move tactics
has to be essentially Flawless in this
previous mattress he was leaving some
points on the table in positions where
Amman and I felt like you know a player
of his caliber should have seen the
decisive blow I think he has to turn
that up a little bit if he does his
positional play his openings are nothing
you know they're unimpeachable mm-hmm
and he carved down to 30 seconds looking
pretty annoyed here it's really hard to
figure this out Donya I've been trying
here myself 56. oh
Counter-Strike and obviously now he
wants to take the Knight
he's got three attackers on it
well that was the blitz chess equivalent
of a critical moment Hikaru spent like
over a minute on that move and he's down
to 20 seconds he's gonna play the rest
of the game in bullet but I was worried
about Knight B3 here that hits the rook
and now your Bishop is hanging right and
with 30 seconds figuring your way out of
that mass even for Hikaru is going to be
really difficult oh but there is an idea
here that involves sacking on F7 and
then taking on G7 and trying to get a
rook to C7
right
and if Knight takes C1 you can move the
bishop back and hit the ninja mezzo and
go for compensation against Black's King
right I mean you can also let the Knight
get out and go Queen F3 to H3 so that
you collect the other piece but head
towards the king already
I think black hat to do that the Ebola
bar hated that move how do you defend
against Queen F3
um what the moment he's hoping that like
maybe bishop D4 check will will be messy
but I think King H1 after that might be
what ding overlooked
yeah
which I looked at with his original sack
and it didn't change anything in the
original sack black could still trade on
C3 and play Queen F2 but here
doesn't look like
black has to give up the bishop and what
makes this even worse is that white
threatens and Knight takes G6 your
Black's King is going to be in huge
trouble in that position as well I think
ding just made a
didn't figure his way out of these
complications
yeah white would also be threatening
Rook A6 in that position so
no but now Queen H3 Knight even Knight
F3 here
Queen G3 yeah now Queen F2 I that was a
weird move by higaro oh yeah you don't
you don't want the end game when you're
up the night against the pawns you don't
want the end game generally especially
with such a weak King
but thing deciding whether he wants to
trade he does
not work C4 F oh you can't play F5
you can play D4
just trading upon or you could try that
I think Hikaru prevented precisely that
King F6 G5 check and the E5 square is
going to be a weakness
hard to evaluate rookie one okay one
makes sense
that was a bad move things should have
gone for E1 and A1 mm-hmm
I think he car is going to win this
probably that's what the smarter chess
prediction said
Rook E3 he's now starting to hunt for
black spots he's managed to consolidate
here his Knight is perfectly positioned
and he keeps looking at what he does he
keeps his past on things just gonna fly
gears one and a half seconds yeah yeah
he's gonna flag wow can't even moves out
the problem is that if ding If he if he
loses in most of these tactically sharp
positions you're just busted right yeah
you don't have a shot you have to find a
way to out calculate Hikaru to punish
shikaru when he gets down to 20 25
seconds and we could just see how smooth
he is even with no time in his clock in
a complex position that game could
explain a little bit the the sort of
semi-contradiction in the Insight where
it was saying that dingley Ren is more
accurate but has the lower winning score
in the long games I mean you can play
perfectly accurately and lose on the
clock right you've made maybe zero
mistakes even until the very end when
you make the blunder that actually
matters right
as tardykauer said the player who wins
is the one who makes the the next to
last mistake yeah but those accuracies
also they won't they won't assess you a
mistake for losing on time
right exactly even though it's better to
play Knight F3 than to flag you're right
that's funny and that's true and Hikaru
here playing a very one could say
fashionable line of the of the Catalan
where black plays this very weird
sequence A4 Bishop B7 looks terrible
right you're giving up B5 and C4 but
black goes A6 and the idea this is a
pawn sacrifice which ding does not
accept but uh you can't take on C4
because you lose the Rook sure I won't
do that you can take on A6 but then the
Knight travels to P4 and the Queen on C4
ends up being very vulnerable so that's
basically the idea
ding plays Knight C3 yeah it is and
Hikaru totally liquidates the queen side
this just equalizes for black right then
it just looks like that Queen's Gambit
accepted variation where black plays
Knight D7 to B6 and has the double
isolated C pawns right
and I think your car seems very
knowledgeable in this line he's still at
450. he looks very confident like time
to offer a draw I've equalized right
classical chess here
yeah the only
thing the black has to be careful about
is you know Knight takes D5 at the right
moment you're not necessarily afraid of
that move but you could end up losing
the C4 Pawn if you're not careful right
in some case after Knight D5 if you take
with the E Pawn white could play B3
right
so Hikaru deciding whether to play Rook
C8 or maybe Knight C6 just develop the
Knight although that's an example of a
position where white could probably take
on D5 and if you take with a knight you
drop something four C6 is hanging still
and here we have three
yeah okay okay
is not shy about taking big things here
early in the match yeah yeah and he was
checking his his mental database there
looking up at the sky he always used to
do that in classical tournaments too
and now he's looking at the floor
yeah I guess he didn't find the move in
his database so he checked if it had
fallen on the floor so he ends up going
Knight C6 I think ding has to take the
bishop this is probably by the way E4
does not trap the bishop due the Knight
before opening up space for the bishop
to move back
I think everyone was actually wondering
about that I actually think black as
night before in this position though
and
and then maybe Knight E4 black gets a
lot of activity and it hasn't even lost
the pawn yet hasn't lost the pawn yet
and in fact the pawn is like being
escorted by the knights all the way to
C2 so right potentially even to C1
yeah and nicaro plays it
dang is thinking I mean white could also
play Queen F5
Queen D2
between D2 I mean there's a lot of
different squares probably Queen D2
walks into walks into 94. yeah then you
have to play Queen D4
right there's even certainly not going
to be an advantage
right according to 294
unclear where exactly you should put the
queen here you can definitely not play
Queen C3 because then Knight E2 is a
fork
yeah
while hikar was definitely not giving me
any bullet Vibes today he's giving me
like classical chess Vibes so far in the
splits match I mean he seems really like
underwinning for super high quality
really focused willing to think hard use
Mainline openings
I think he's done a great job in his
sort of mental Scouting Report because
as we described in the insights
uh ding does have a very high overall
accuracy and probably he is one of the
most precise accurate classical players
in
you know among the top players which is
saying a lot yeah uh you know nepo might
be on the other end of the spectrum
where his overall accuracy might be
quite low in comparison but obviously
he's extremely creative and when he
makes good moves they're really really
good so Hikaru could have said to
himself okay I'm not taking any undo
risks in the opening I'm going to play
these long games
and given how precise thing is and how
good he is technically my top priority
should be to equalize he doesn't mind a
few draws here and there right and he
actually might be making one here and
maybe he's curious how ding uses his
time if he plays some long drawn out
games it's not like he's offering a draw
or anything like that right he's just
playing like for something more equal
and solid and then see see how ding
responds to that
and by the way I feel the need to
clarify what I said is not meant to be a
knock on nepo
I think nepo himself would never has
said this before uh that you know he he
can tend to be sloppy of course
comparatively to other top players right
uh but he's more full of creative ideas
it's all you know it's all a spectrum
it's all you're better here you're a
little bit worse there everybody's good
everywhere
my excuse for really low accuracy play
when I was playing was that I was
purposely creating more complicated
positions for both myself and my
opponent would be making more mistakes
um and I obviously nepo's like in seven
different levels but
um there may be an element of that that
he also gets more mistakes out of his
opponents with uh the difficulty level
of what he does
and a draw
we saw Hikaru 982 Knight B4 repetition
he probably could have continued but
like I said he doesn't
necessarily feel like he has the need to
take crazy risks with black and we see
them repeating the line from game one
okay it's going to be one of those
matches I think so both players
satisfied with this and I think that
there was there was no action in the
first game that would tell you like oh
my gosh I have to jump ship for my
opening right um it was definitely not
decided by the opening so I could see
both players like going back to the same
thing uh rather than them really feeling
that one player or the other got the
advantage in the opening choice
yeah I mean I don't remember what dink
played here I think it was Bishop F5 but
don't quote me on that and rookie1 is
aimed at preparing Bishop F1 again as we
discussed White's main plan here is
ultimately to surround the safe or pawn
and White's also got a lot of these uh
helpful improving moves like Rook C1
maybe 95 at some point so yeah hard to
why why wasn't black able to play A3 at
any point is that like was there never a
moment to do that
if white plays Knight B1 here it's like
oh I have a discovery against the queen
but black was a6b2 and makes a new Queen
and then white can try to trap it but
fails did a queen take state two what a
line
that only would have been so proud if it
captured two queens and two moves
right
he takes A3 believe it or not because if
black takes it there's this very
unpleasant night jump to be fine maybe
this is possible but it it seems a
little bit a little bit iffy the Knight
gets to C7 yeah I don't know anyways
Bishop F5 has been played Bishop F1
Queen A7 and H3 yeah I guess black just
doesn't yet have the development at that
point to take advantage of the C file
but the idea of A4 A3 would be to sort
of
undermine the night on C3 and then have
some play on the C file anyway they're
in a stodgy position like last time this
time Black's thrown in the move H5
um to reduce White's possible pushes
there but it weakens G6 a lot if white
can
put the King on G2 to defend the king
side pawns and then bring the bishop to
D3 later and pressure G6
there's something to work with I just
don't love these having these positions
against cicaro like like I said before
the match started positions that are
objectively equal but where there's a
lot going on under the surface not only
is Chicago incredibly fast but it just
knows how to create practical problems
and and how to make them essentially
unsolvable in the context of a Blitz
game and I think we're starting to see a
little bit of that here in the first two
games where he's white
yeah
and the black screen is not great either
and we're seeing it on the clock right
now I mean
I I I try to look at these things not
through the lens of like I expect a car
was going to win the match so everything
he's doing is the right thing right but
but as to the point that you're making
about making sort of practically
impossible for the opponent I mean look
at that time lead that he has there of
like two minutes like straight out of
the opening
you know he flirts with the repetition
and there it is again and now it
declines it with Bishop G2
and again ding has to decide which of
the minor pieces he's taking I was a
little surprised that he took the Knight
on C3 last time I was more leaning
toward this idea that I mentioned but
Knight takes it to Knight A5 yeah
um maybe he'll try the other flavor of
this game
and and one of the components of of this
practical play is forcing your opponent
to constantly make decisions
now you never know which decisions are
truly important so you don't know how
long to spend on them and
you know that that is even a thing
decision fatigue it kind of drives you
crazy when you have to constantly decide
well do I trade this piece with that
piece you know do I push this Pawn or
that on the car always puts you in these
positions yeah here by the way folks
Knight A4 just runs into Rook takes
Knight so that's
that's not upon the ding is hanging
sorry oh you're saying anything
and then the bishop under two hangs yeah
although
you could take on e4
afterward but oh do you take C4 Queen A4
Bishop B3
no idea forcing Rook takes C6 right
another sacrifice and then Queen and
Bishop A5 would be insane look at this
bro okay eight
I love these sequences where you have
like eight you know a million Desperados
in a row oh yeah
the most and that's a funny one in any
case the cairo's turn now
to think he plays the the solid Rook C2
defending the B-2 Pawn he is
relinquishing some of the pressure on A4
but this is his top priority
yeah a safe move and and leave the
pressure on uh 94 is going to basically
be off the table because of Bishop B3
for black for a while so he's gonna have
to figure out how to
you know pose his next question to ding
right make the next like annoying
threat I wonder if queen bees might be a
move coming for white at some point Zane
just made a nice move I think the idea
is oh he's trying to kick the Knight
away and then play Bishop F5 and create
more problems Against The Rook yeah
yeah that's annoying good spot and
hikara just agreed he just went like
yeah that is annoying
yeah he has that slightly concerned look
multiple annoyance
and the Evo bar slowly creeping up in
Black's favor
maybe even it's time to consider
something concrete like E5 in some
position
although I last opened that Bishop pair
well the downside of that is that of
course you'll get the iqp structure or
the D4 square that white can occupy in
blockade so Rook ac8 could be oh no no
then you hang A4 oh that's annoying
that's why it's annoying yeah it is
annoying
um
and maybe Queen maybe Queen B3 could be
like a little creeping move a little
Zinger
because now I think Knight takes G5 I
don't like that move yeah
I feel like Hikaru can sack The Exchange
and then in the end he can take the D5
Pawn
even with the bishop even with the
bishop and guess what that pawn on G6
you mentioned a while ago that could end
up being hanging with the queen on C2
simply attacking it
yeah it's a big deal okay he gives the
exchange
and
now which way to take
I mean Bishop D5 E6 defends it but then
there's Bishop takes E6 with Queen G6
great Point Ocean takes D5 E6 Bishop
takes C6
and then Queen takes G6 when there's
this unopposed light squared Bishop I
always want to try and like block it off
with my pawns like I want to play E6 but
no so maybe it would have to be king G7
the other thing I'd like to do is put my
king not on the color square of my
opponents
yeah and then movie Hikaru can just drop
his Bishop down to A2 because Bishops
are just as effective
even more effective when they're out of
the way and operating at a distance
and man I like wet Center I like why
it's night I can jump out to E4 at some
point and I like uh hikaru's time
Advantage this is a very concerning
position for dang yeah all right King G7
that's what I would have done and Bishop
A2 that's what you would have done so
yeah and now the pawn and A4 is hanging
I'm not sure dang eats this I would say
the top priority for black is somehow
bring his pieces into the game
maybe go E6 at some point to blunt the
bishop
ding is down to a minute on the clock
though yeah
it's gonna be tough
yeah I feel like he needs to get it
White's King there's no pieces around
the white King right now yep and he
listens to you
all right is it dangerous after G4 I
don't know if it's dangerous or not it's
just the direction I was looking
yeah that's the direction black needs to
try to play and unfortunately black also
doesn't have too many pieces on the king
so yeah the idea I was trying to make
work out with some version of like Rook
C8 E5 then White's generally gonna play
D5 to try and keep our Knight out and
then setting up Knight D4 because
we need to somehow transfer piece to the
king side here well ding had a minute
he's taken 30 seconds
and so bring the queen to D7 and play F5
yeah interesting idea I mean of course
F5 immediately
can't really
make happen he does play E6 on Knight E4
Hikaru could also take on A4 and get his
Knight to C5
yeah which I think he's gonna do
yeah
uh dropping the pawn for nothing and
it's not fun yeah now why does a
material advantage and now B4 Bishop B2
is another idea and
create collinear Bishops that both are
aimed at Black's King
this is nasty there it is yeah it's
long-term a lot of pressure but
when you feel like that also all of the
thousands of games I played against the
car made it and made me a little better
at guessing his moves but it does not
help when I'm playing yet
now I would say you would you could move
the queen to pave the way for 94.
you don't want to go D5 prematurely
because then
you allow Bishop F6 and you get into
trouble yeah
yeah and in general with that pawn on G4
I feel like White's happy to keep the
center closed for the moment and squeeze
until until black runs out of ideas I
think
date of maneuvering the Knight to C5
could be really nice use your Pawn
majority on the queen side so Bishop B3
to cover the C2 square at some point
Queen on E2 expand on the queen side
and 14.7 seconds is not an amount to
ever want to have in the middle game
against the car or ever
yeah or in the end even if you're up a
queen and you have 10 seconds you're
basically busted you'll find a way to
complicate it yeah I don't even like to
have four 14 seconds on my clock when
I'm facing Skyhawks 59 over here I mean
I I just don't like 14 seconds
right not a reassuring him out Queen F3
and 94 looks like an interesting
reshuffling yeah okay covering the C2
score with the Rook that was unexpected
I don't really see why hikaru's not
moving his Queen I mean it seems like a
very natural concept and he does move
it's going to D3
because and that's why I suggested Queen
F3 because then ding wouldn't have been
able to move his King back yeah of
course this is still really good I mean
look at White's position but oh yeah not
quite as convincing as I thought it
would be
well basically black needs to be able to
play B6 now what offers the queen trade
that was a surprise
and dig declines it instead centralizing
his Knight but higara's time Advantage
has dwindled considerably he's got 25
seconds himself
he's not making too much progress on
either side of the board and then can
play B6 chase the night away and he'll
have the C file
yeah
all right B6 Queen B5 hitting the Rook
nice move staying with some very nice
moves here and some nice play in time
pressure he's moving fast and so far
moving accurately but down to five
seconds
Caro could consider the move G5 at some
point to lock up that King side yeah
look at the eval bar just before he was
sitting around gyrating and promise of
gymnastics there ding is just saying his
car was doing nothing I'm gonna play my
moves as fast as possible for the moment
I would be shocked to pick our repeats
moves here I would be absolutely shocked
I think he's going to try to go F4 or
something something very risky
um
no he's reshuffling getting his Knight
to F3 just don't go E4
it's that Knight F4 is a fork G5
he's just gonna pick up the the H fun
um
black Detroit Knight takes before here
okay maybe Knight six before existed not
anymore
he's never going to trade any of his uh
his Bishops you're never going to beat
hicarot his own game not in these
positions I mean he's just gonna
steamroll him on ow GF and E7 Queen
takes G6 it's over
Bishop C1 is a nice move too
oh yeah Bishop C1 would be nice there it
is there it is a little late but better
late than never
ooh apparently that was a mistake but
Queen F7 oh who knows wait that's one oh
my God it's gonna get mated on each
three there's three queens oh my
goodness
he's gonna flag what
oh my goodness unbelievable huge howler
by Hikaru forgetting about the H3 Pawn
there
the winning move may have been King H2 I
mean that's so easy to forget about
and if I may just really really quickly
recap what just happened there this is a
completely winning position
I mean but yeah with three seconds
understanding that this H fund is
significant look at dig parking his
Queen on h8 yeah what presence of mine
any cargo and queen F7 looks like it
ends the game because you're gonna make
a new Queen they're going to be up a
million pieces but no Queen takes H3 is
simply Checkmate the last piece hey in
these time scrambles
it like this happens like this just and
that's the first threat of the game more
or less
right like exactly plus for southern
thread of the game was that was the one
that won them the game it's like when
you have a wire to wire basketball game
and the buzzer beater is the shot that
gives the team the first lead
yeah they've been behind by like at
least one point for for the entire game
seven minutes yeah Hikaru is not gonna
tilt I think if anybody has watched
dakaro for more than one match you will
know that he might display on his face
you know a lot of disappointment he
might be the most emotional player but
that may have something to it by
displaying emotions on the outside he he
releases them and I've never seen him
tilt like I have other players or he'll
just give games away he'll never give
games away
okay so ding just switched openings
slightly I think he switched from three
Knight F3 to 3 Knight C3 allowing a
nimso instead of going for a Catalan and
uh one thing which our our viewers may
or may not know about dingley Wren is
that at this point he's one of a
dwindling number of players who only
plays
1d4 versus D4 and E4 and I remember
I remember that like
it's not that long ago let's say 15
years ago
it was there were only a few players who
played D4 and E4 even at the top most
players were either in four players or
D4 players
and now most of them are Switch Hitters
at the time it was like a big deal to be
a switch hitter now it's kind of a big
deal that Ding never plays E4
right
I mean I guess yeah it is even people
who have been traditionally only four
players even you can take nepo he
started playing C4 Sergey karyakin you
know is one of the the E4 Role Models at
the top even he has sort of branched out
he started some D4 games and the reason
is because the the necessity to uh to
escape your opponent's preparation has
far outweighed uh the the sort of appeal
of playing something that you know that
you've played for many years it's just
much more important to get your opponent
into fresh territory yeah yeah one of
the bigger one of the bigger changes in
top level chess in the last you know 10
to 15 years pretty rapid
um but as far as I know dingley rent
always plays 1d4 yeah no he does he does
you expect him to stick to it 100 in
this match
I think unless there's a trolling phase
in the bullet where you see some bomb
clouds yeah the H4 h5s I think there's a
high probability he sticks to to what he
knows best and we have a name so Indian
here this is a very old school line this
this structure with this Pawn triangle
and the blackest pawns on C5 and E5 this
creates a lot of tension in the center
neither side wants to be the one uh to
Flinch first
in the center basically white really
wants to get rid of that C3 Pawn that C3
Pawn is the bane of The Bishop's
existence on B2 and the bane of White's
existence so if white ever does
something proactive in the center
they'll be leaving the C3 Pawn on C3
um and black ever makes trades they're
trading off the C3 Pawn like it looks
like you're taking on D4 but really
you're getting rid of the C3 pawns so
right yeah they're kind of they're kind
of stuck there for now
yeah they are and now the knight move it
moved away from F3 the temptation to
capture on D4 has has increased and
probably hikar was calculating that
ding is trying to get his own Knight
probably either to C4 to B3 which is a
classic maneuver in this line
yeah it's quite a calculation what
happens if black just starts taking on
D4 right here
I'm gonna wash my hands of that I don't
really feel like
and yeah Hikaru did the calculation for
us he plays e takes D4
and he's almost certainly going to take
on D4 again there it is
I don't get what they got in mind
because the problem with Knight B3 is
you give up the A4 pawn and you give
like connected passwords on the queen
side the Knight C4 seems pretty
innocuous Queen C7 and congratulations
what do you do now or queen B4
or maybe not going before Bishop A3
actually traps the queen
that's too bad because otherwise it
looks like a weak spot like the queen
would be happy to be talking to those
white pieces they're not on squares
defended by pawns but yeah Queen C7 with
cicara's Tracy takes D4 and an iqp
position where black has control of the
square in front of it I think ikaro has
no issues in this position
yeah I mean I just want to play D5 for
white here no I don't have a follow-up I
just I want my B2 to open I'd rather be
down a pond
I think ding may be preparing something
of that sort he goes 93 let's see if
Hikaru puts a knight on D5 himself or if
you just stays in control that's where
Queen B6 also looks like an interesting
try
although I might be doing your bidding
for you
there it is
yeah
and hikara might very well grab the pawn
on D4 once the bishop moves
yeah I don't see a compelling reason not
to at the moment
um
oh there'll be 94 Bishop D4 Rook D4 yeah
yeah it seems like you can just take
straight straightforwardly
yeah basically the bishop on E6 is going
to be defending the other Rook which is
going to allow you to leave the eighth
rank
and here we go
yep he takes it
yeah Pawn is a pawn
is a pawn but hey I'm happy the bishop
is uh yeah by the D4 Pawn
yeah maybe just Bishop F1 or something I
don't know
and notice that and notice that the like
cherished uh evaluation bar didn't care
too much when white lost the pawn it's
just kind of like
you could be down your Bishop on A1 or
you could be down your Pawn on D4 but it
doesn't make a huge
difference yeah White's very active
there's no appealing discoveries and
what tends to happen sometimes in these
positions is that white somehow wins the
pawn back but it comes at the cost of a
lot of Trades so there's a lot of draw
potential in positions like these
we'll see if vicaro plays Bishop B6 to
try to neutralize the light skirt Bishop
a car was thinking which is nice because
if I were white I wouldn't really know
what my next move is we would you have
any advice for me here Tanya white yeah
it's hard to find improving moves like
you can't really Target this Knight
I guess I move like Knight D5 has to be
considered and then Bishop takes D4 but
it's a little bit speculative
yeah yeah I'm not I'm not exactly I
don't think ding is threatening anything
for which reason Hikaru might just want
to play H6 for example just create some
list but I don't know I'm really
attracted to Bishop E6 here
yeah so you don't have to worry about
Knight D5 right he's taking a sweet time
he's now down on the clock
yeah this isn't the major tank right
here
yeah like you said ikara has not been
shy to take a minute and a half even two
minute things in the five minute portion
and
five minutes is a an ocean of time for
these players that are used to Bullet in
three minutes it's just completely
different yeah
all right I was looking at a very very
fancy full blender for black which was
Queen B4
basically to just hanging all sorts of
stuff the Knight on D4 The Rook on
um E1 so I was had in mind Bishop D4
Rook D4 that's a nice idea or on some
other move by white I was setting
something up even more just outrageous
which was I was trying to threaten
Bishop takes H3 for black with my queen
before move oh you want to play Bishop
H3 and then something like Knight F3 and
queen takes you on Queen takes exactly
Queenie that's a cool idea yeah well you
almost called it you played Queen C5 and
ding responds with Queen B1 getting out
of the out of the potential zone of
discoveries yeah I was thinking white
might even play Queen V1 next to trade
Queens if black sort of just sat because
I just couldn't tell what else what it
was going to do yeah and one way this
position could fizzle out is the guard
plays B5 ding takes the Knight on D4 and
then takes three times on B5 so
that you have a liquidation and a
symmetrical end game a car now down to
30 seconds though
I mean he's got to be careful this is a
wide open position he does go for B5
let's see if ding goes for the draw or
maybe takes and goes Bishop A2
yeah he goes for the draw yeah
fair enough my car was in agreement
Rook D1 you could even play here too
liquidate extra maybe it's not over yet
why does marginally more active here
yeah as long as the bishop on C4 is
hitting F7 which is sort of the only
real weakness in the position at the
moment
then I guess Queen takes Queen and queen
back to E8 yeah ding is definitely gonna
make a couple moves here I mean
it's a little unpleasant yeah
I just don't see Hikaru losing this
position yeah
yeah if it were the other way around you
might you might be worried about about
someone having 20 seconds against
hikaru's 50 but for Hikaru 20 seconds is
fine
right
yeah I mean in a position this simple
there's just no way he
yeah if you commits any kind of serious
blunder and okay ding basically offers a
drop like yeah
it's enough
let's see if they repeat or if they
agree to withdraw they clearly have had
some practice recently in tournaments
where the format says you can't offer
draws right right very quick at coming
up with the moves that sort of
quickly liquidate right yeah
the one thing no GM will do in those
situations though is make the final
trade into that like King and pawn like
Bishop E4 like you don't want to have to
calculate if you get to explained at the
end so yeah no no no definitely not and
and that's one way to lose these drivers
when you start playing on autopilot and
then you all of a sudden get into some
lost end game okay so that game will be
aborted we will go on our traditional
mid segment break so far ding hanging
with Hikaru the score is 2-2 after that
crazy turnaround game but David of
course it's way too early to make any
Grand conclusions we will have to to
wait until one of them gets separation
yeah you're kind of feeling each other
out at the beginning here right it's
taking the message of the opponent and
we've seen that in in many of these SEC
matches so we'll see how it continues
you're watching the speed Chess
Championship semi-final presented by
coinbase we'll be back with the rest of
the five minute portion in just a few
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
chess.com is proud to release game
review a simple streamlined tool to help
you learn from your games immediately
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy and how many brilliant and
great moves were played then select
start review to dive into the game learn
about the opening and get helpful stats
on your performance
retry mistakes to learn and improve your
accuracy score
see why moves are played thanks to the
coach's feedback and click show line to
see helpful engine recommendations play
a game start review and try it today
love intensity I love matches that are
difficult and I think the world rapid
and Blitz it's like exhausting for the
players to play that much speed chess
over over multiple days in a row so I
love watching that event
yeah no I I love it too I think
everybody does and the time scrambles
watching watching time scrambles over
the board is one of the most
entertaining experiences
that you could possibly have and the
disputes that sometimes go along with it
I think it's a healthy dose of as you
said intensity
and uh great way to uh to celebrate the
new year
okay so we're waiting on the resumption
of our second SEC semifinal Hikaru
Nakamura and ding liren to determine who
will challenge Wesley so in this year's
SEC final
well it's 2-2 David again like I said
before we went on break it's too early
to conclude how the start of this match
has has borne out on the rest of its
course nobody has momentum I don't know
I I'm not sure yet I still feel like
like they're like they're figuring out
who their opponent is today
um a car making these super expressive
faces
I would not even too much into it like
they haven't started the game yet
exactly he's reacting to I don't know
and they're right I
maybe he's reading an email I wouldn't
say it like means that you know he's
he's like not happy about the current
score or anything like that right so
yeah and I think like I said Cairo makes
a lot of faces but I would judge by his
moves and even when he's had difficult
matches
I mean he and from personal experience
he's just so hard to tilt and if he was
the kind of guy who got tilted after one
disappointing game you know he wouldn't
be Hikaru Nakamura you can't have Total
Domination over the Blitz World for 10
years and yeah react so strongly to one
disappointing result yeah yeah that's
nakura rickamura who you've never heard
of and you've never seen him play in the
SEC Championship but they've got an
account on chess.com they get tilted
they go on because it binges and the
rating is thirteen hundred not thirty
three hundred or a Slicker would say
hikamaro
yeah
all right so
we have we have yet another one of these
relatively symmetrical positions now in
this game ding did not fan keto his own
Bishop so we have a little bit of
asymmetry
uh with respect to the center now of
course white can snag this Pawn Yeah but
that would not be a very wise idea would
it now got upon dangling but not not as
good as when uh as when Fabi did it you
know I think when good players do
something people want to copy it so that
wait why did Bobby do it Suddenly It's
Like on the table that like you can
sometimes trade
I I analyzed that one on stream it was a
very powerful moment for a lot of people
because people wait you couldn't yeah
like you said you can do that like
that's that's a movie you're allowed to
make right but not here here you are not
allowed to give up your feet and get a
bishop the circumstances were different
in that game yeah yeah E3 is not helping
to allow it either so nope that Bishop
is a required piece for white here and
um
let's see I mean one option here is that
the Rooks just come to the center and
start trading but are there any like
exciting plans for Hikaru as white here
first of all you can prepare a four in
some of these positions for example you
can step aside with your king and try to
go F4 especially since Black's gotten
the Rook away from the King side but
again clearly by his choice of opening
secara was not looking to to take those
kinds of risks I think he doesn't even
mind the tied score at the end of the
five minute portion given how much of a
favorite he is in the lower time
controls as for other plans I don't know
maybe play A3 at some point maybe go H4
just because I feel like Grand Masters
are required to go H4 in some of these
positions
watch your cargo H4 it's like a unspoken
law oh first he goes
a31 contract one for one a three on the
queen let's see if I can go two for two
and he'll play H4 on the next move
maybe ding plays A5 and then he car is
like all right time to play on the other
flank right
yeah that's it's a good point you make
though like the way he's played it
shouldn't be a surprise that the match
is like tied so that makes it even less
likely that he would be frustrated about
it
um because it does actually feel like
this should be well within what he could
expect with the strategy he came in with
right no for sure and we've seen this
type of strategy in this previous SEC
matches as well he has not gone H4 but
it's only because ding allowed him to go
before I was a little bit surprised I
honestly thought Bing was going to go A5
um this seems like a little bit of a
concession even though the eval bar
hasn't really changed
yeah
I mean
my my main advice to ding for a position
like this would be to play a couple
moves quickly and wait to see what
Hikaru is really up to
he's not really heating that advice no
he's taken about a minute on this move
97.95 is another maneuver that I've seen
in these types of positions I yeah I
don't really know I I agree with you I
think there's a lot of moves that are
about equivalent and strength I don't
think dig needs to stress too much
okay but he goes A5 so he does go for a
pretty confrontational idea yeah he sure
he wants a car to go B5 my other advice
for Ding and for other people is not to
take advice from people who are 400 or
500 points lower rated than you right
but the thing is when you're a
commentator I think people sometimes
interpret these statements that way but
I I think you should be allowed to point
out you know clear
you know things that a player needs to
do I think that's actually kind of the
job of a commentator but yeah of course
I mean otherwise like the only people
who'd be allowed to comment would be
like you know Magnus and and Ding and
people like that and then what they
would be commenting and we'd be playing
they'd get all the commentary right I
know although nobody likes a a Monday
Morning Quarterback but there are some
commentators I watch a lot of sports
and I draw some inspiration from some of
my favorite commentators there's one uh
basketball commentator his name is Jeff
Van Gundy uh it comes from a basketball
family his coach is also a coach he was
a coach he was coach of the Houston
Rockets very successful and then he went
into commentating
and what's funny about him is he's
always pointing out what the players are
doing wrong and he's arguing with
certain basketball rules but everybody
loves them and the reason is because he
does it in such a funny lighthearted way
nobody thinks that he's about to run out
of the basketball court and tell Steph
Curry how to shoot a three-pointer right
he respects the players in the game but
he points stuff out
but it's a hard balance to find for sure
yeah
he coached the Knicks too the chat is
reporting in the meantime Hikaru is
starting to
you know get us tentacles on on the
queen side here Queen B5 hitting the
knights yeah and if the Knight moves
away then B7 is saying although A3 is
also hanging
what's notable to me is that the white
Bishop on C3 and Knight on D2 are a
little bit loose so as black I wanna
if possible breakup
that coordination for white so that the
lack of stability on those pieces is
going to matter
but at the moment we just have to do
something about the Knight right so it's
either it's either B6 or or retreating
that is surprised that icaro has
tentacles come on I was always saying
there's an octopus how did people not
know that
come on chat us out of the loop B6 B6
so yeah Queen takes B6 Queen takes B6
Rook B6 Bishop Bay three we've got a lot
of hanging pieces everything I have no
desire to calculate this position
oh that's your job
am I jumping to calculate yeah never
yeah Hikaru is definitely thinking about
that if he doesn't take on B6 he has to
defend A3 so I guess he could play
Bishop B2
although then then you'll have problems
with the Knight yep dangling
once the queen moves
okay time about balanced little Edge for
Caro Bishop F1
not capturing any of the things or
defending any of the things right he
just ignores it entirely I guess the
point is yeah
it should be to the Rooks not hanging
with check on C1 and after Bishop C5
maybe Hikaru was going for some sort of
initiative with Knight E4 I'm a little
skeptical of that but and I think so is
ding oh dang skeptical too
yes he is you can also Play Bishop takes
C1 Bishop takes B6 and we've got another
Mass exchange and I'm not sure how to
evaluate that one either
yeah yeah not clear at all but I think
okay so he goes through Bishop B2
the evil bar doesn't like that move
right I think for the reason of your
Bishop C5 move
well they're going for the line
yeah now Knight B3
although there I could play Bishop takes
D4 and queen F7 yeah
so
good catch under a minute though and
this is what Hikaru does the position
has remained very complex
and he's somehow built up a pretty
massive time Advantage there it is
Knight B3
now if he moves his Rook where does he
move it Rook C2 would be natural he
plays Bishops before but definitely
takes in Queen F7
and I think he missed it
Queen F7 what a luck
right and Rook 64 there is Knight A5
or Knight D2 trading the knights and
ding is basically not risking in this
position
no he's looking he's very very safe with
his extra Pawn and uh the second rank is
even more scary than the B Pawn at the
moment to me
for sure I think Hikaru is definitely
the one who has to
exercise caution and he he's doing just
that going for the trade of Bishops and
he's going to pile up on whatever lands
on C5 whether it's a bishop or a pawn
yeah I think your car should be able to
pull out a draw here yeah the black
queen is is far from F5 but if she got
there that's where things would get
pretty scary
so hakara wants to open up the queen
side
um before there's time for maneuvers
and Dayton's like all right go ahead H6
he also has to watch us clock because
Hikaru can complicate any position
doesn't matter how Josh it seems
you don't want to end up with two
seconds for the rest of the game and I
think we're going to see a trade and a
draw Queen D7 is a good move for just
drawing up the game if you're if you're
done trying to win
right
now the question is which repetition are
they going to are they going to find
here
or are they going to trade down really
quickly until Rook versus Rook
so ding did pretty well in that game
yeah no it seems like black yeah he's I
mean in the middle game he's he's
playing no worse than icaro
it definitely seems like
his time consumption is not going to
carry over very well into the three
minute portion so not to say that he
won't be able to make adjustments but
Karo is ending most of these games with
with a hefty time advantage
yeah and that game honestly it could
have still been complicated it was just
because ding had a slight Edge he was
able to Parlay the slight Edge into
simplification right but if he'd been on
the other side of that game which
obviously he wasn't but I mean if you
were on the other side then the 20
seconds could have been a problem so for
sure
let's see back to the Catalan
back to the Catalan
and we have a very fashionable line
everybody's playing this move C6 now
which used to be unheard of around 2014
but someone somebody like kramek played
it and you know you know what happens
from that point on everybody starts
playing it yeah
and it's a good line
because the bishop on G2 is somewhat
blunted black can still prepare C5 at a
timely moment so I think it equalizes
pretty heavily
okay well E2 is is hanging so black is
solid solidly uh coming with the Knight
on D5 could trade it as as desired
can come in next
yeah you'll you'll often see black
playing moves like Rook C8 sometimes the
Knight will go to B4 a square weakened
by White's move A4
and for ding I mean trading on D5 is
tantamount uh admitting that the opening
hasn't really worked because after a CD
it's a comfortable position for black
yeah although that is the kind of
position Hikaru has been happy to play
as white so
yep
yeah you're right ding is such a pure D4
player Catalan Catalan Catalan you know
Wayne's Gambit he uh he got wild with
one Knight C3 allowing the nimzo and was
like yeah you know right nimso is a good
opening I'm going back to Knight F3
right coming back to home base
yeah but you could try something like
Knight D5 Queen C6 or a fc1 like if if
it were in your strategy to play like
very equal positions right insteading
taking on B5 I would imagine higaro
recaptures the a pawn because if you
take although you could take with a c
pawn and open up the C file for yourself
but a little bit too
Brazen now you're right it does take on
D5 yeah well if I was right about that
he's going to play Queen C6 too right C6
no I agree I think that's that's the
only logical way to follow it up you
give like one move black face Queen you
get tricks and everything seven two
though yeah same type of idea you're
trying to harass black before black has
managed to consolidate yeah no why does
why does white is better here
without a question that's something to
say then
I just didn't I underestimated this
queen C7 idea because if black plays
Queen C8 white Show's gonna play Rook C1
White's not gonna budge same problem for
black yeah and at that point Black's
already losing a pawn
um after Rook C1 pretty much like the
b-pawn's already gone yeah because in
the end game the rook's gonna come out
to B7 blackstroke is going to be tied
down to the Knight
you're right
yeah
and then once white takes on B5 it's
made in 23.
right
right yeah ding brings his Rook to C1
anyway getting full control of the C
file yeah how is Hikaru going to
untangle here I mean he could play
bishop f8 and free up the Knight problem
is the Knight doesn't really have
anywhere good to go
yeah
I mean is white threatening anything if
White's not threatening anything I'd
even be inclined to play Bishop E4 for
black here just so the bishop on G6
doesn't get left out of the game
and you're creating a potential
potential trait of Bishops
yeah Bishop E4 looks looks pretty solid
I I don't think yeah I don't think ding
is threatening anything in particular
here it's just an uncomfortable position
for black
yeah
buddy Caro once again taking one of
those long thinks that he's
taken quite a few over the five minute
portion
yeah as we approach 30 minutes remaining
yeah we've got one each with three draws
and
um this has been largely a a choice I
feel of nakamura's who's the more like
flexible players about player about like
Styles and stuff I think it's a choice
of his that has made some of these games
so solid
um
yeah
and you know we can definitely ask him
about that in the interview uh whether
this was a conscious strategy or just
you know just the way he felt the
mattress going but I really don't have
any doubt that
he kind of planned planned this yeah and
one 95 came from ding that was something
I was like toying with in my mind that's
why I was thinking of Bishop E4 on
and after 95 white collects the bishop
pair for the moment yep
C3 and now white wants to play next you
know B3 and Bishop B4 yeah the Knight
looks good but it's it's not stable and
ultimately white can also go E3 Bishop
F1 and play against the B5 Pawn yeah
which shikaru defends with a rook V8 and
okay B3 is very natural he plays it
yeah and now I guess the Knight has to
go back to B6 not something you would
want to do but
I think you have to Queen A3 oh that is
his stupid mind attacking everything The
Rook on it on on C1 white yeah you got
it yeah and now the Knight wants to
escape the SC2 mm-hmm
yeah the night is kind of Trapped but it
also has a lot of Escape Routes and it's
hard to attack
yeah and then you go Rook A8 to A1 for
black and the position's locked up
enough for a draw yeah
um
E4 right here
and your ID is d e Bishop before I'm
trying to trap that Knight E4 I think
black has B4
and then I can take your problem yeah
yeah that's a good try though what I was
thinking is Bishop B4 and Bishop C5
actually does threaten E4 so
this does become a major problem for
plaque yeah the car instantly goes Rook
C8 1964.
before night before
or either actually
yeah
and if you go E3 then I can still Escape
via B4
that was quite a move Rook C8 and he had
it he'd seen it coming way before right
I missed the chance to point out that uh
ding actually had a two-minute lead on
the clock at some point this game
um
so the car was feeling uncomfortable but
now he's he's figured it out with that
right well it might be for still it's
still uncomfortable Rook A1 and then if
you play Knight D3 white can always
support the bishop with B4 and still the
B5 Pawn worries me in the long run is
white is just about ready to start
attacking it with Bishop F1
yeah so if I'm a car I would I would
still be contemplating either Rook A8 or
even E5
try to liquidate by force I actually
like E5 here yeah I think Rook A8 the
problem is this E4 move that
because if Rook A1 comes black loses the
pawn on D5
yep just a template too slow to go for
rookie eight and you can't go B4 because
if Bishop takes before
it's a double-edged pin both sides so is
there anything wrong with your E5 idea
oh he goes another Direction B yeah he
goes he goes for B4 oh I guess his idea
is if Bishop takes before he has Rook B8
winning winning the pawn back okay
I believe that and if E4 then still he
has Knight takes D4
mm-hmm so
an important moment here for dang you
can play Oh King F1 just ends up getting
sent back with Bishop D3
I thought maybe bring the king to D2
right
so I mean if that's no good then Bishop
F1 is the only other move that's really
improving White's position I I looked at
Rook b193 wasn't impressed
um so yeah
I don't really see any other piece that
can be improved other than Bishop F1
yeah it's quite difficult to say
and then taking one of his own deep
things yeah Bishop takes before rugby
just seems like essentially a draw
and we might see another draw yeah
okay G4 I think he wants F well no he
can't really play F4 because the pawn
hangs
so he's passing hikar the move and kind
of asking Hikaru how he's gonna improve
his position which is not easy either
okay
well if that's all he wanted to do he
should have done it sooner
right
yeah he took a while to make a pretty
straightforward move and Hikaru does
allow E4 yeah
oh maybe E4 Knight A1
Pawn takes D5 Knight B3 yep
[Music]
what uh
weird complicated position where I could
go D6 there
okay we're about to see something like
that
I was trying to decide between D take C6
and D6 I think D6
is the more ambitious move yeah
I agree and he plays it and he plays it
Bravo and I think he car is in trouble
here
maybe Rook d8 but then rookie won
Rick D1
I just don't see it for Hikaru like
what's the move yeah I don't see the
next move here either B8 the evil bar
approves of that wow
now if that was the only good move
that's like amazing when you find like
an only defensive move with 10 seconds
yeah and it's that calm just Rook V8 now
white stroke is hanging white has to
move it I would imagine rookie one
because Rook D1 might run into Bishop C2
although maybe you want to provoke that
move for whatever reason right
ding down to 25 seconds it's players
three results are possible here by the
way like white could mess this up yeah
like if you go rookie one maybe black
gets Knight D2 and then yeah okay well
ding has to make a decision here he's
down and there it is Ricky E5
but these seven Rook D Bishop C6 I guess
and I still think
it takes but The Bishop's gonna move
away from C6 and White's gonna give up
The Rook for the B Pawn and push the C
Pawn Yeah ding is completely winning
here Bishop A4
this is easy
C7 huh and ding's gonna win this game
oh my goodness very impressive
very impressive
seizes the lead and we're indeed six
good time management that move G4 kind
of keeping the tension very patient
and you know hikar got along time he
strikes with E4 and Vicara wasn't able
to find his way out of the complications
a great great effort by ding
and he needs more where that came from
am I allowed to say Donya and and if not
we can just go back and cut this out of
the VOD but am I allowed to say that I
was hoping that dingley Wren would win
the five-minute section so that we would
have more question about who's going to
win the match in the second and third
time controls I think you are I think
most people understand that
is always a root for a close match
that well some people don't understand
that and I feel like
any time you praise anyone for like a
win you just assume it's a knock on the
other player which is ridiculous of
course yeah I I definitely think there
would be a lot more entertainment value
than a close match
yeah I once like very very early days
commented a kids tournament
and then a parent sent in a complaint
that I had said something good about a
move that their kids opponent played
right like I was like that's always a
good move like why did he say that about
the other kid final biased I didn't know
so biased against against my son yeah
how dare he prays a good game by anybody
yeah
what a controversial Point yeah yeah but
what I really love are like you know
chess contests where you don't know
who's gonna win yeah everybody does and
Hikaru is built up this like like you
know Aura of like invincibility in the
speed chess championships so I would
love to see him lose the five minute
portion and see like how like what is
what what gear does he go into if yeah
for sure and I think a lot of hikara
fans would like to see the same I think
it's normal to to want that you know I'm
a big Warriors fan and I I don't like
games where they're up by 30 after for
the first quarter I I like to see buzzer
beaters in you know fourth quarter
contests that come down to the wire
just I mean most people are are into
entertainment and this is definitely the
most entertaining type of match and
we've seen a lot of it in the SEC this
this season we have not seen a lot of
blowouts which is you know a testament
to how much everybody has left
everything
on the table and uh in the good sense of
course and uh there have been some
matches that have gone down to the very
last game
two of them I think
A5 wow
that's a very desirable move for ding to
get an a5a4 if possible but I was
concerned that white might be getting
ready to move Knight E4
um but I guess it doesn't matter too
much
black is another lackluster opening by
Hikaru who's given up the center
he's given up Queen side pressure as you
as you've said and
his Bishop on B2 is that impressive as
well you would want to at some point
play E3 but completely not feasible here
with a white black Bishop on C5
it was King H1 King H1 a bit of a
miserable move right yeah I mean black
can play Bishop G4 black and play A4
this is a a chance for ding here he like
I said he I think he needs a two or
three point lead realistically out of
the five minute portion and he needs to
maintain that in the three minute
portion
yeah but this is this this is the chance
this is the the format where I think
he's closest in strength to Hikaru
yeah
have you seen ding play Blitz outside of
the speed chess championships like very
little
because I know you sort of like play
with all the the highest rated Blitz
players online I think I've played them
maybe once or twice but he he doesn't
play a lot casually which hurts you I
think the most in the bullet actually I
think that if you're a good Blitz player
but you don't really play much online
you come back you play a couple of games
all right you're back in into the
routine in bullet I feel like it's
almost impossible to find your form
unless you're very practiced
right and in that Sensei Caro has a huge
Edge over a lot and certainly the
opponents certainly a 30 minute
SEC segment you don't have time to find
your form right like nope you you would
need to have like a two-hour session and
maybe in the second hour you'd be like
playing well but
but here it's 30 minutes and it all
counts against you and the depressing
thing about playing guitar is that even
if he has a complete disaster you know
you beat him you're winning by six
points going to the bullet your lead is
still not safe you're still very much uh
nervous that he's just gonna whitewash
you and 30 minutes is enough to play 10
or 11 games
so in the meantime dig continues to
extend his advantage in this game
he's put the bishop on B4 he can put the
other one on a six for example and then
he can put the Knight on D5 it seems to
be dominating in the center mm-hmm
or or Rook B5 yeah I mean fiancado
Bishops just generally are not that good
if the opponent's Center is too strong
so
yeah Basics slicing from the side here
yeah freezing a lot of White's pieces in
place and if you go Rook G1 you could
end up you know getting mated with h24
it's actually not so easy to defend
against the threat of Knight takes F2
believe it or not given that the Knight
on D4 is also open Knight on D2 is also
finned yeah no I mean you just have to
go straight back to F1 there
um
yeah I just bungle this totally bundled
it
um I don't see a move
yeah I mean each piece can't move
because of the other piece that can't
move right to untangle it climb can't
move because the Rook can't move
because the Knight can't move because
the queen can't move it's tight of the
night the bishop is blocked by Black's
pawns what hikara needs is some
he needs to make one of Black's pieces
budge or he has to play F4 at some point
how is he going to change the course of
the game of course he is
second to none in this regard
yeah he does not have lashed out with F4
there so it's it's instructive to see
what he's doing here well he's
preventing smothered mate and then the
night before he took that threat
seriously and now eventually maybe bring
the other Rook
away although you can't do that right
now
and for ding you know it's hard about
these positions in Blitz is you feel the
need to find accurate moves you feel
like you're so dominating that you don't
want to lose your advantage so you end
up burning a lot of clock
you know sifting through a lot of
tempting options
and dang for the time being and this is
what I've liked about the way he's
played this match so far I think he
understands when he needs to play a
little faster today but he doesn't do
the thing where he spends a minute and a
half
he understands that he can't really drop
down to 10 seconds in the middle game
right can he play E4 here
like speaking of oh
AIDS can definitely consider it and the
point would be again that the Knight is
pinned white would have to sack and
exchange I would imagine
yeah
and then the game enters a decisive
phase once you go for it plus three
Queen E7 also makes some sense it's
going up because it's white you can take
on e4 you just play E3 next move and I
assume White's position is cracked so
yeah White's position is just fed
through the shredder then
everything collapses
ding taking his time I can assure you
he's calculating E4 he goes A4
striking on the other side and guess
what he's threatening Queen A5 which is
gonna enforce the pressure on the Knight
oh ouch
this is a strong strong move it's a
great move and it's a no risk move too
Bishop C3 makes sense here yeah or you
could go for the pawn take D2 and take
B3 again I think ding needs to make this
decision fast yeah
but she's not really doing
and he goes for Bishop C3 keeping the
tension I like that I just your idea of
Queen A5 is so evil
and it can't be defended against for the
reasons we outline because of the Rook
because of the pawn because of the night
and icaro is insistent on giving up a
pawn but relieving some of this pressure
now Dean can go 95 or he can say this is
what I'm talking about it
it's got a lot of these ones
he's completely winning here
but can he drive it all the way home
I think this game he can
I think this game he can there's the
exchange sack yeah
okay now he takes P4 as well
ugh yeah it's an exchange in a pawn no
compensation it's not a pawn for the
exchange it's not compensation is an
exchange and upon and compensation yeah
he's got you know Lock Stock and Barrel
and Hikaru does manage to put his Knight
on D6 that's like the first active
species at all game yeah
the first white piece to venture past
the third rank right and there comes
it's vis-a-vis
which can swing backward to B5 if ding
once and force the Knight out of D6
one thing that concerns me this clock is
there anything wrong with Queen A5
Bing is wondering the same thing
well I guess he just has nowhere to go
after reaching A5 there's an ip5
24 seconds hicaro keeping as many pieces
on the board as possible but now the
Knight is banished to age four
and The Bishop's going to reroute I
think to E6 and potentially to D5 yeah
it's hard to hang out like on the other
side of the board when there's nobody
else from your team there right it's
just you and like five guys who hate you
like at some point like
ding trading the 9 out of five nights
Bishop takes B3 there say Carver trying
one last attempt to weaken black sync
that is not a bad attempt I should say
no not a bad attempt I would have played
Queen E7 last move because of this thing
wait F6 G7 was ding's idea does he want
to play E3 must be E3 but then just
after the queen
I don't like the direction this is going
for dang he's got 10 seconds that's what
I talk about five seconds
three seconds ah
Queen takes H6 now it's unclear look at
why does the G file Queen takes C6
oh my goodness now he didn't even lose
this game yeah very very well might now
you can't go Rook q1 immediately you
drop YouTube you could go Bishop F3 and
threaten Rook G1 yeah or Bishop C6
and agaro King H2 but white could still
lose this game as well oh now he could
Queen the a pawn there was a Pawn on A2
there was a reason for doing this
Queenie
oh that was dated Queen E5 Bishop F4 oh
my goodness I think ding's gonna lose
one second left
now white is winning apparently
oh E4
I think E4 is the move
hey Carlos like calculated annoyed but
he's gonna win
unbelievable turn I mean this is what
kills you in a match with your car these
games they destroy your morale and they
destroy your match score yeah I mean
then you can ask the player like did you
lose the match because this move like
hurt your morale and they're like no I
lost because then I gave my opponent
points and they were ahead of me and the
reason this happens like I I'm a broken
record here but you cannot get down to
10 seconds in a Blitz game with your car
it doesn't matter how winning you are it
really doesn't
uh and I think a lot of players who are
less experienced with the car they don't
fully realize that you can do it with a
lot of other players you can't do it
with the car because he will always
trick you in one way or another he will
always find a way to create
complications as he did in the last game
this the moment he played F6 I had a
feeling he would win the moment Hikaru
plays such a move you just know that
things are about to get
you know things the tables are about to
turn yeah yeah that that's tough because
they're when things personally in the
match and you can see him still like
upset about it I mean oh yeah he's
thinking about it until until that
moment where he lost that game I hadn't
really caught a facial expression on
ding in right first you know
70 80 75 minutes of the match and when
he lost that game he looked upset and he
still looks upset
yeah I mean who wouldn't be it's
impossible not to be because
you know it's like
in the span of five moves it's it's day
and night
crazy and icaro equalizes the met the
score
yeah he's also unhappy with the
positions that he's getting I'm sure and
I think we'll see some changes in the
opening from him and the three-minute
portion
mm-hmm although he's got a very nice
position here
now this game here you I feel like with
the one second increment it could go
like 11 12 minutes but there's a good
chance to get one more game in after
this in the five minute portion yeah I
think most likely they will okay
so two games maybe to go here in the
five minute
yeah dig to not tilt away two of both of
these
yeah now Rook C8 and C5 is the typical
plan yeah definitely a bright spot for
Hikaru is like how how comfortably he's
equalizing with black in the opening
yeah he seems to really really have his
Catalan lines down
and uh you were saying the reason people
like move their openings around is
partly because if you get stuck in the
opponent's prep like you just can't do
anything so
for ding I mean he doesn't seem to have
any weapon with white so far
no I think he's probably going to stick
to the Catalan and
I mean he's he's getting complicated
positions so he's maybe he's just more
comfortable with these types of
positions although here he's got to be
careful or his Center is going to
collapse uh one idea I was thinking of
is E5 and then eventually get this D2
Knight baby to E4 and D6 we'll see what
he decides he's already a minute down
yeah
I think he's contemplating whether to
play E5 here or or to you know just take
on C5
let's see
yeah he's taking
pretty long think
yeah I would definitely think there's
one more game after this one
yeah
well he's got that it's got that feeling
of like you know super GM classical
tournaments it's like a real struggle to
prove an advantage for white these days
in the opening you know
the five minute portion in general feels
like classical and it's interesting I
think one day I'll write a book on this
like the history of online chess and you
know the attitudes towards various time
controls is really interesting because
I've been around for a while now
um I'm ancient with respect to online
chess uh it used to be the case that
people played I played five minutes and
three minute in regular quantities and
bullet was it was like black caviar it
was a delicacy right all right at the
end of the day I'll play two bullet
games now well it might be
quantitatively the most popular design
which well 32nd was absolutely not a
thing and it didn't have to do with
pre-moves it pre-moves existed but 30
second chess was unheard of until maybe
a year ago so it's just interesting to
see how at five minute now is basically
tantamount to classical
right crazy how how much the attitudes
have changed at least in my anecdotal
experience
yeah
yeah you're right so white has the
possibility of Knight D6 always has to
reckon with the Knight takes E5 tactic
but when there's a rook on C8 you could
play Knight D6 it's just after The Rook
moves
what's your follow-up
so
he's offering the nitrate which takes
the pressure off E5 ding of course
plunges in to keep the pressure on
and yeah and he might follow up with
Rook C1 to hit the other night
yeah I'm not sure what that Knight is
doing other than just coming right back
to try and threat to Knight E5 again
my back yep there we go running 95. and
that might necessitate Knight E4 or
Knight C4
complicated
middle game position he goes 94. yeah
eval bar didn't like that move
Knight D6 with a draw the eval bar wants
right it's already speculating on that
no Rook C8 Rook C8 is a nice move get
control of the C file
and Knight T6 is not going to be a
problem as long as the Knight remains on
D7
ding activates his Bishop
attacking A6
I mean A5 is
natural but now Dingus has to be five
square if he wants it
yeah
although it's it's always dangerous to
get your Bishop away from you know
that's like the goalkeeper coming in for
a corner kick it's like you never know
when you might have one one you know
somebody kicked the ball from one side
of the field and you don't have a goalie
it's the equivalent to these tactics
along this diagonal I think G2 is
definitely looking like the goal post
here right
all right the Knight comes in it's back
on why because black snipe went away
from D7
and uh interesting that black doesn't
that hikara doesn't go for the trade
just pops back feels like he's being
made to suffer a little bit
um
and you know white has to be very
careful about F6 at some point because
the whole position could collapse in a
second if black plays F6 and you've got
a knight on D6 that starts getting loose
the f file opens
I like Bishop C6 you got to get rid of
this bishop I was getting really worried
about
this diagonal on his behalf
yeah now the a pawn is in a little bit
of trouble right is there any tactic
with Rook B6 Knight B6 Knight F7 ooh
that's really cool and then
I think that deserved to be investigated
black might have to have given up two
works for a queen there
okay and steady plays Rook season five
five instead but leave day four hanging
yeah but is Chicago going to take B2 I
think his his Nike would have gotten
trapped there after Rook a two oh that's
a cool trap and he saw that in military
you probably saw that 10 moves ago he
goes to create instead and the issues
that if ding takes it and goes P3 the
car is just going to jump back to C5 and
White's b-pawn is a lot weaker than
blacks black speed Pawn is perfectly
safe it's controlled by the Knight and
the Knight is anchored by the pawn so
if anybody's if anybody has minuscule
winning chances it's probably black
yeah
yeah once you reach this point I think
the extra space from E5 is a
disadvantage in these uh in these end
games
the Cara moves this Pawn down to B3
where it's under the supervision of the
other Knight
a lot of Night Moves yeah ensuing yeah
fantastic moves from dingley Ren move
after move
his dad can be very proud of him
wherever right
well the thing is yeah Knight D3 is
coming ding down to 30 seconds
look what your story started in the chat
I know
who could have predicted that that would
have become the daily copy pasta and
that's why I'm saying hi to all 57 of
his fathers right you gotta watch others
everybody's like you know now the
dingley runs famous you know they want
to be his dad I want to be like all
right they're emerging out of the
woodwork
okay so Rook A4 now the knights are
indirectly skewered by The Rook
and again guess what ding is down to is
down to 18 seconds he has to get rid of
that beep on if he gets rid of the beep
on I think he can draw that with any
amount of time
yep and he does he did Knight C5 Knight
D3 he does he could he did he would
Cara's gonna make a couple moves here I
mean White's marginally worse yeah
the one thing white wanted to do which
was Rook d8 check King H7 and then the
Knight coming into D6
your car could have almost taken that in
gun King F5 but then white has 96. yeah
oh who making the whole thing there four
seconds is okay
it's okay for now Jane cannot afford to
lose this game
well I say car is so disappointing you
play the normal game and he's slightly
better in the end game I don't know if
that's
what he's shaking his head at yeah
I mean
when hikar doesn't win I think he's mad
that he didn't win when he does win I
think he's massive even better right if
the game wasn't smooth enough I mean
what do you want me to do yeah
except a car says that to himself the
game wasn't smooth enough yeah
you know
after the last game that he won where
ding got upset I actually saw his car
looking very upset and he was doing a
gesture I associate with Magnus you know
where he's like putting away the game
like all right all right yeah yeah
Magnus does that all the time at the
hand yeah a hand wave emotion eye yeah I
was like watching Magnus he's like
picked up one new move for his body
language this game is completely
unacceptable once
totally unacceptable yeah
yeah he definitely does that okay hikara
might want to push his F1 oh he really
can't because if he plays F5 didn't even
take on Passat and you can't touch the
Knight because of F7
that's too bad back to home base
and uh dings only used .7 seconds so
right it works so far is still trying he
wants to get his Knight to D3 yeah
okay King f8 96 Knight D3 what do you
think here what's the issue with them
she very tricky doesn't want that F7 pun
pinned
oh look things down to five seconds
uh-oh down to three seconds
Knight D3 is a nasty little move that
Hikaru created here yeah ah but didn't
coming back around and taking G5 good
stuff good stuff G4 hikar not giving it
up easily no
he's trying every chance every single
move that he could try that has any kind
of trickiness he's trying it yeah yeah
and he's got some pressure on this game
he does yeah if Jake loses one of the G
pawns guess what akara's gonna play this
for another eight years yeah
yeah and then it's going to be the last
game of the match
it might set a record for the longest
this game has been going on for 10
minutes already yeah
getting the night around jumping around
to F5
intense
before for the moment
yeah the Knight defense both bonds and
the Knight is also anchored by The Rook
so your car is going to have to find
some other setup if he wants to keep
pushing maybe get this f f Knight around
okay dingo's G4 that's that's a
commitment that's another 50 moves
commitment at least right and we and it
weakens the F4 square if black plants
and I don't have four like right about
now
yeah that's gonna be pretty nasty Knight
F4 Knight H3 I don't know why your car
is not doing it there it is
he's made some progress here
yeah
right back to G6
around to E5 and here comes the king and
he's tied dings Knight down again yeah
1964 he loves the pawn there it is
there goes one yeah why there's no
chances here I mean you can't do it with
three seconds
icar will torture you until the crows
come home to roost and then he's going
to win the second Pawn Yeah and things
playing a little bit like me when I'm
out of time he's just looking like he's
like can I make one random check can I
like put one piece here safely
one move at a time
so far Hikaru not able to make further
progress yeah Harry's got night seats
one minute left in the match and
okay
got to be a little bit careful for black
not to repeat although we haven't seen
no there because the Rook you lost the
Rook oh what a move oh oh my goodness
that is that is so mean
oh that is and now he has black for the
last game that is just devastating
yeah that is just devastating
and that's what ikara does that this is
just what he does and what he's always
done
and
nobody can compete with that kind of
pressure that he puts yeah
and that was that was the long game that
was the long game that was the
eventually like somehow he gets this
like you know 70 plus percent score in
the long year yeah and and let me show
everybody how he's losing The Rook the
point is that if you go to the fourth
rank you walk into a fork
yeah uh if you if you play King F3 or
King H2 then you walk into a discovery
and once you lose the exchange you're
going to lose the pawn and you're gonna
lose the game so
that's a quick breakdown
and let's see if Dane can pull it
together and avoid losing the last game
yeah
which he absolutely has to do
yeah you know what would be a funny line
here is Knight G5 H6 so page seven check
and that's mate I know this line yeah
but unfortunately uh black has other
ways to defend the h-pawn
Hikaru castling instead
six to cover the area
another relatively
non-threatening opening adopted by
Hikaru but could play B4 here and clamp
down on Black's Queen side
yeah Black's overall plan is to play C5
in this structure so B4 will have to
maybe prevent that
the bishop G4 is surprisingly annoying
the Knight on F3 doesn't have a lot of
prospects it can go to E5 anymore
so it might even be worth playing Pawn
to H3 and
preventing the Bishop from
from developing to G4
impossible to say what a car was
thinking
five he invites C5 yeah I mean I looked
at this for a while and I figured like
well C5 why would we do this so let's
see Hikaru had a deep thing maybe he'll
tell us why here
well show us why he seems unhappy but
then again
what else is new
he can be up 15 points in the match and
make one inaccuracy in the bullet game
and you will see a lot of head shaking
yeah
well we'll look forward to that
C5 yeah we might actually that's the
kind of thing we might see
then go C5 yeah
you know I think Hikaru might have been
planning DC BC and then B4 but and of
course if C takes before there's a fork
on C7 the thing is Ding and ding can
throw in the move A6 whenever he wants
and I think that's what he's gonna do
a6b5
now white is worse again oh yeah that's
really white is much worse
why does white is simply in 94 is also
possible here
white is white is simply worse yeah
yeah A6 I I love that I love just a6b5
like I Black's grabbing this like space
advantage and E4 as well like restrained
without being occupied so
yeah I like the way he played it I'm not
in a hurry to trade the Knight on F6
um
yeah again Hikaru has slipped into a
very passive position with no clear plan
and now he's down on time as well that
doesn't mean anything
but no it just it's just something that
allows us to judge his confidence level
right yeah yeah when when he gets lower
on time he's not going to blunder but we
know that ding's doing well in the
position yeah I mean queen B6 A5 and B4
is is the traditional way of continuing
the pressure but you know he doesn't
have to do it straight off the bat
yeah oh he's doing the exact maneuver I
was thinking of even though the bishop
on C8 was on an open diagonal I was
thinking like I would go into my Bishop
on C6 here right
yeah I think so that Bishops defend good
pawns and he's preparing A5 it restrains
E4 at the same time as supporting the
queen Side Pawn push so it's doing
something important with itself
and I would expect to 94 at some point
or B4
Hikaru probably wants to take the Knight
and get the other one to an active
Square
nothing really changes the evaluation
here ding just has to decide hey you can
play Bishop D6 and prevent it if he
wants
let's see what he does
yeah
time Advantage dwindling
and this is of course the last game of
the five minute
yeah this is a tough decision for black
right here
it really is there's I mean Knight takes
F4 also has the benefit of damaging
White's Pawn structure but it reinforces
White's control of the E5 Square
so very very hard to decide
and there it is 95. you have planned
here this is the position where I wasn't
sure
what the justification would be
white didn't want to trade on B4 because
of Bishop A4 we can't allow that
um but that's good news for a car we got
the bishop to back off
yeah he did and there's no immediate
threats on the queen side I guess yeah
he takes A3 was
getting the bishop back to its feet and
get it score threatening a potential
Knight takes C4
due to the PIN
although Maybe not immediately because
black guys work C8 in response yep
but uh stuff that Ding has to worry
about
Queen B6 would be logical helping The
Rook on E8 get involved in uh the task
of queening one of Black's Queen side
candidate pawns definitely
the Cairo might want to consider putting
a rook on the a file to contest it
Bishop C8 getting the bishop around to
F5 yeah
and Knight takes E4 is met with Bishop
F5 and the White Queen is no good
squares
okay well right now Bishop F5 looks like
he'll be awkward so
white needing a move maybe
F3 and E F3
yes and he plays it just as I was about
to make the move the move made itself
comes right under your mouse yeah yeah
F3 that was for that reason excessive
elimination like I was like what else
does white do but right there is very
little and Hikaru is insisting on he
before he moves his King away so that
Queen takes D4 will not be a check yeah
um is he threatening to play for I don't
know ding has to decide where he wants
this bishop you can put it on E6 so that
it solidifies the center
Bishop F5 would kind of walk into E4 so
I'm not sure that makes much sense
and he's taking his time here
contemplating the various ways to meet
E4
I would consider G5 G4 for black hair
trying to carve out those light squares
a little bizarre but just based on how
important E4 is yeah for sure
he goes Bishop B6
okay
he's got to respect Knight takes C4
right that's that was in the air
right yeah now he puts puts that to bed
and icaro has to decide and Bishop C1
here would reinforce the idea before but
that would close down the first Rank and
black might have Rook A1 Everything is
unpleasant here
I mean yeah
this this looks like an incredibly nasty
position
yeah
I wonder players are having fun this
looks like really hard work at the
moment but then maybe at the end they
say like oh yeah I enjoyed every minute
of it right
well I don't know if by their facial
expressions it's hard to hard to say
that they're enjoying it too much right
yeah that's why I wonder because like I
think when I play chess it also looks
like I'm just like suffering you know
it's like you're trying to solve almost
unsolvable problems while like ticks
against you and
and you know you pull out your hair and
stuff and then afterwards you're like oh
that was the best ones that was that was
the greatest experience yeah exactly
well it's funny yeah that always the day
after the tournament is usually I'm not
I don't want to look at chess I don't
want to look at my games that was so
stressful
and then a week later you're looking at
the tournament calendar right I want to
go here here and here this is where I
want to play exactly what you said yeah
by the way have you had another
tournament since the US championships
anything yeah anything U.S Masters us
Masters that's right yeah I did okay I I
mean I lost the second round
but I I avoided a total disaster so it
was
it was it was a reasonable tournament
I'm definitely going to play more this
coming year yeah you had fun there
yeah the time of my life especially
after the second round okay sorry no but
what was fun is that it was obviously I
could stay at home
and because it was in Charlotte so it
was really
fun from that from that point of view
and the games I I won some nice games so
I had some fun attacking
now that sounds good so Knight D7
trading the Knight on E5 which was kind
of oppressive and the F3 Pawn was
dealing with the Knight on F6
yeah if he goes for that trade do you
think like the trade overall like leaves
black with good winning chances as like
pieces come off the board what does
Blackboard have left on the board well
eventually black would want to go C3 I
imagine just make use of this Pawn
majority for okay they're training a
bunch of Pawns but he's let Hikaru take
the pawn on C4 eliminating the majority
all right White's position is still
flimsy Queen F2 or something at some
point and
after work C2 White's position is just
full of riddled with weaknesses
this is very Queen comes back to like E2
or F1 here this allows Rook C2 this
should be three with Tempo Queen C7 also
attacking E5
but higar can
oh Bishop C4 Rook takes C2 wow nice nice
find B3 anger now you don't want to take
that do you white is completely lost
here once again can he pull a rabbit out
of the Hat
yet another time
probably yes but what's the rabbit yeah
Bishop C4 is coming
it's incredibly nasty Bishop G4 I guess
there's Rook takes C2 okay ding decides
to Simply take on E5 maybe not the most
testing and he's got to watch for some
perpetuals with Queen d8 Queen H4 by the
way right and he's got Bishop D4 ready
to start I feel like his Advantage is
somehow beginning to evaporate
imperceptibly bit by bit yeah maybe it's
already evaporated
I think Queens off the board would help
white to to hold so
I understand white offering and black
declining
I think to take advantage of this kind
of space Advantage you usually need like
a rook or a queen like a kind of people
come into A2 or C2 huh yeah so maybe
those trades were worked against dang
and Cara's gotten as Queen to d8 what's
everything's defended for white so I
really don't see how black can even
equality content for anything here ding
declining the repetition I mean he's not
really risking
immediately
immediately
draw
okay so that's going to be the end of
the five minute portion there's going to
be an hour of three minutes left half an
hour of one minute left and Hikaru comes
out of this with a one point lead
exactly as predicted by smarter chess
various smarter chest now I have to
begrudgingly admit kind of riding a
streak and uh for Hikaru this is a dream
a dream result I like I said I think
given his opening choice you wouldn't
have minded uh sort of a 50 50 result a
one point lead going into two time
controls where you know he's like a fish
in water
is is a dream scenario for him ding is
going to have to uh you know pull his
own rabbit out of a hat uh in order to
contend with Hikaru in the subsequent
two segments
we'll see if that happens we'll see if
that happens but first we'll let the
players catch their breath and we will
do so as well you are watching the speed
Chess Championship presented by coinbase
we'll be back with a three minute
segment in just a few minutes
[Music]
all right
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
chess online or learn how to improve
join us at the number one chess
destination in the world chess.com with
thousands of people playing at any
moment you'll quickly find a game with
someone at your level whether you're a
beginner or a Grandmaster chess.com
makes learning fun and easy sharpen your
tactics with puzzles and enhance your
strategy with our lessons by top Masters
learn from your own games with our easy
to use analysis tool chess.com has
everything you need to take your game to
the next level signing up is free and
easy join chess.com today
The Puzzle Battle World Championship is
back you watch the very best puzzle
Specialists compete for their share of
the 25k prize fund catch defending
Champion Ray Robson GM mvl GM chakri
armamandara and so many more it all goes
down January 6th through 9th starting
daily at 9 00 a.m Pacific noon eastern
time and 6 p.m Central European Time you
certainly do not want to miss the puzzle
battle World Championship
I don't know who that is yeah I don't
want to talk about that you mean the one
on the right the top right yeah yeah
there was somebody who you definitely
didn't give their top billing to I I
can't believe they invited they invited
that person to Puzzle Battle I didn't
announce it because I was so you know I
think that's such a bad invite right
yeah what's he doing there you know
those who can should play and those who
can't should comment right exactly what
are they doing
well Hikaru is is playing pretty well
here in the SEC he's up a point against
England in our second semi-final as the
three-minute portion kicks off and I'm
very curious to see how you know
particularly hikar was gonna adjust his
opening place he's gonna start playing
more ambitiously
and to try to extend this lead
and so far we have a very
like another very quiet opening as thing
with the white pieces and
game one yeah nobody's touched their
e-pawn with white before moved 10 yet in
this size
yeah there isn't much one E4 going on
not even four on move seven like it's
just
stuck there this just looks like a
complete bailout I mean literally
everything could be traded in the next
in the next five moves both Bishops the
queens and then maybe the Rooks down the
D file
it's possible one can hope then white
plays King G2 King F3 and wins the game
off of King activity right exactly I
think ding is both players have
calculated the inevitability of that
yeah puts a lot of pressure on black
like if you can't keep the white King
off of F3 what do you do here
yeah Rook f51 perfect
step one
step two
yeah
and we're about to see step three
although hegar doesn't have to take on
G2 he can just play Rook d8 yeah but
then white plays Rook D1 you trade on D2
and again like it's hard to keep the
white king off
right
yeah reacting half breaking a forking E5
very
toothless game here
and ding will have to make stuff happen
to the white pieces I I don't see him
having a chance in this match without
getting significant advantages
because if every white gay man's in a
draw I mean the car was more than happy
with that
yeah I mean I would say daily Run's been
getting good enough positions with white
and with black overall
um strategic play good
but when he's got to push a car over the
edge he's got like under 20 seconds left
and his car Slips Away
um
there was one game where it looked like
he could maybe win without ever striking
a blow just like smother Hikaru the game
where he got the pawn on D4 is black in
the opening oh yeah amazing complete
division he allowed F6 and somehow it
all came apart I mean he was up like an
exchange and a pawn with a better
position and just one little [ __ ] in
his King side yeah I mean technically
technically F6 allowing F6 was not uh
the mistake but
you know he was still completely winning
but you just start to when he car does
something like that against you
uh higaro punishes you immediately just
immediately you know he just senses
blood all right you've got 10 seconds
here I'm gonna just throw my Pawn at you
here again and the game is going to be
over
ultimately I mean hikara was frozen by
the night on E7 couldn't challenge the D
file so he eventually makes that trade
on F3
and uh
the pawn on e4 getting in with the way
of the king I don't know
yeah yeah his his campaign to March the
king all the way
the black's territory is has been halted
yeah stalled out it's too bad the eighth
is uh incoming I think at some point
okay Carl playing B5 very Bold And if
Knight D6 is gonna go Rook be it and the
knight's gonna be a little bit trapped
on B6
right uncomfortable night
I guess you should go Knight B2 here
just to be safe
and then maybe Knight D3 Knight C5
yeah the least safe would be the move
that I would play which is Rook D7 and
then some move like Rook C8 and I lose
my pieces all right whoops yeah yeah
try to make Dynamic use of the open file
right like before blacks
challenging me right
I don't know maybe a little bit little
little something here for white and
Hikaru down to below a minute ding
obviously is like I said an excellent
technical player and he will create
problems for you in these
you know maybe he's got a minuscule
advantage in the end game but he's got
some squares five square wait Rook takes
D3
oh my God Cairo had Rook takes D3 a
night before yeah and I think black is
winning here because in the end what
happens I think is that black can take
on F4 and play G5 and that's it yeah
it's over to win
oh my goodness that's why when you're
agreeing to a draw and just trying to
trade off some pieces always leave one
piece on the board because the king upon
endings can surprise you right but that
is an extremely uncharacteristic
oversight hikara sees that stuff
automatically and usually in less than a
second
yeah
so that's a big time Dodge Bullet by
ding who continues now to apply pressure
he might get the Knight into C5 yeah
while leaving the tension between the
Rooks yeah this is gnarly
he trades on E5 first I still think
Knight C5 looks pretty
powerful
um
although I don't know I guess these has
reservations about something
yeah he plays it finally goes for it
oh yeah I can understand why he traded
on E5 it's because in these positions
here he wouldn't want the E5 Pawn to
trade on F4 right because that's like
his one weakness to attack so I guess
King King e14 B6
and then you're gonna see a repetition
of moves as ding gives a check on C70
Carl brings the king back yeah
and Hikaru very accurately here
neutralizing whites and game Advantage
so he's not gonna win the game but he's
not gonna lose it either
yeah
yeah well that's fine that's fine yeah I
don't think thing has any other choice I
mean he could go 96 but I would be
playing with fire
yeah we're gonna see the repetition
and uh again Hikaru wouldn't even mind
the three minute portion to end you know
with a 50 score like he wouldn't mind it
too much yeah whoa A3 dang
trying to create chances here
will he play Knight D3
I would say that's mostly risk versus
upside for white because in the night
upon endings that outside
yeah on majority is pretty scary so
that's why he's trying to go for this
one he wants a prime majority outside
majority of his own uh and on G6 I think
he wants that a fade and idea whoa oh
okay here I feel like White's risking
slightly I
I agree because black could create you
know A5 A4 and all of a sudden White's
losing so didn't going B4 shutting that
down
but it's still aha now Knight B8 going
after the a pawn Hikaru goes after the
d-pawn and we still see liquidation
that was fun a very unexpected result of
this game
although it's still not over you know
something could still happen it's a
night end game after all yeah I think
your car was playing for a win
yeah threatens Knight F5 Knight F5 King
D5 King D5
no he goes H6 but didn't can go H5 now
H5 here
yeah I've played this this exact kind of
position out against the computer
um hundreds of times Dania and uh I
always lose like even with just two to
three pawns on the two sides locked
symmetrical
yeah the thing in that end games is all
it takes is attacking a single Pawn
Knights are bad at maneuvering
themselves to you know to defend pawns
so somehow it's it always seems to
Hikaru
kill you know the little King pilgrimage
to the age file
yeah
and the draw in the first game but yeah
night on games are very tricky that's
the the upshot
okay another double fan ghetto I
actually double fianchetto he played
this pretty much exclusively on Tuesday
entitled Tuesday
um yeah he likes this this opening in in
important events
I think in in casual Blitz he plays
majority one E4
but I noticed that in SEC matches he
actually rarely plays E4 until the
bullet okay
which is I don't know what to say about
that I think dings Marshall
and Berlin is a pretty good reason to
avoid 24. that's what I think
yeah
yeah fair enough but um I mean but ding
has had no trouble with this opening
either right it's got to be said like
like did you get him out of his opening
theory yes did you get him to play any
bad moves in the opening no no and I
mean nothing your car is doing is smacks
of you know ambition I again I think
he's he chose the strategy he's adhering
to it
uh he's getting these relatively dry
positions a lot of the games are ending
in draws
and and he believes that if he keeps a
one or two point lead into the bullet
that's going to be
you know more than good enough uh yeah
so which is a completely valid way of
looking at things I think he is as I
said the extremely heavy favorite of the
bullet but we have seen some
unexpectedly good bullet performances
even ding has not been too shabby in the
bully we can't beat Iranian like that
yeah
A4 a car is striking at the queen side
yeah this is hard to say anything
specific about this position black is
doing Flying here
I mean the C2 Pawn looks a little bit
weak so
I guess the Knight on C4 will cover the
file so black would have to figure out
how to deal with that
your car giving up his feet and get a
bishop but
yeah forcing black into an iqp and white
still has his other female Bishop that's
the great thing about a double field
kiddo yeah
maybe Knight F3
I just wouldn't have given up that
Bishop yeah ding immediately opens up
his own light skirt Bishop like I feel
like when ding played that way allowing
the isolated Queen Pawn he was thinking
well on ev5 I'll take with my knight and
white would never take with the bishop
right now this was definitely unexpected
but you've got to be careful yeah
White's other pieces are all essentially
an optimal of course maybe with the
exception of the D2 Knight which can
migrate over to F3 and you know black
could end up losing the D4 opponent at
some point yeah if they do and that
Bishop comes out from B2 it can suddenly
just completely be over
yeah saying offering a queen trade which
is accepted now hikar doesn't really
have to worry quite as much about his
King safety yeah
yeah and there's the first threat to the
D4 Pawn
yep it can be defended with Rook d8
that's the only way to defend it
yeah
and maybe Knight fe5 that's the pressure
off C2
yeah no Hikaru is pretty comfortable
here at this point no
no real danger Knight d294 is another
maneuver that could be considered
oh there's F6 yeah I was just gonna ask
you if white could play Knight D5 at
some point to eliminate one of the
difference before but yeah
too late that train has passed has left
the station 85 solidifying his own Pawns
yeah a lot of maneuvering here a lot of
back and forth
what I could see happening is either
black ends up losing the D4 upon which
isn't necessarily a death sentence
I don't really see ding playing for a
win here even though the email bar seems
to think the black has the edge
yeah it just feels uh stuck to me at the
moment so
Bishop C8 maybe going to F5 and
ultimately targeting C2 which is on a
light Square
for instance Knight F4 Bishop F5
and if you take on D4 you're gonna walk
into yeah Bishop takes C2 or even Bishop
C5 here
and then once the Rooks are traded black
starts mopping up all the queen side
pawns that could that could get very
dangerous
foreign
Maneuvers to attack D4 Bishop comes out
from an f8
the pawn is attacked more times than
black can defend it with that C8 Bishop
right
so I mean dean could play Bishop F5
planning I think he might have to have
all the trades I I just don't see how
else he preserves if I'm Bishop G4
forces Knight E takes D4 but that works
out for what I think I agree
same thing I was just looking at it
ain't going for 95 so he's aiming at the
F3 Square
so if white takes he may be just placed
positionally like Bishop B7 and
increases his control over all these
weak squares in White's camp
well if white takes with the oh yeah
yeah okay it takes up this Knight
gosh what's going on here lots of
knights that are hanging
the car just wants to simplify with you
know Knight takes C5 and Knight F3 he
could take on D4 a couple times here
playing Knight F3 check take five yeah
and it's gonna be mutual destruction why
it's gonna go Bishop B6 and you're just
gonna take all of each other's pawns
yeah everything comes off we might see
something similar oh he did something
else but now Knight C4 I thought right
and there's going to be maybe some sort
of a repetition
right with the Knight on A5 and Bishop
going to B6 Knight C4
okay icaro has found a way to preserve
his extra Pawn
well if ding wanted to draw the
variation I said was just like shake
hands
now black is totally I'm not risking
here given his extreme peace activity
you're gonna see it trade on D2 and
bail out on a draw I thought or maybe
ding is still playing for a win he
thinks his piece activity is enough to
give him some chances
maybe it is that that backs up what
you're saying he's looking for an
outside pass Pawn the thing is you can't
really play King G4 because of Bishop F6
yeah and any car prevents it entirely
it's white can't really move but black
can't make any progress and didn't kind
of acquiescence to that
yeah the car with the accurate move King
E3 by the way stopping King F4 and now
the most fascinating stage of the game
a bit of a yawn-inducing couple of games
here to start the three minute portion
but yeah you kind of again I think ding
is the one who's got to take who's got
to take more risks again easy for me to
say that but you know Hikaru is is just
Waltzing through the three minute
portion getting it closer to the bullet
and and not not losing his lead
right
okay they just took 10 seconds on the
first move
yeah
oh borrows a page from hikaru's opening
up another King's Indian attack and
transposing into a Catalan and back to
the bread and butter
yep now there's recently people have
been playing a lot of moves other than
C4 in this position A4 C3 Bishop F4 I
don't know why ding is taking this
Unholy amount of time to reach the
mainline Catalan position you can see
your car is just pre-moving basically
yeah
yeah I mean it's 30 seconds down already
and we've seen this line before
and ding did not get anything out of the
opening in that game like your car went
Knight B7 Rook C8 C5 and
black is doing completely fine here I
don't know what thing is hoping for
well that's probably why he was burning
time in the opening was he was trying to
think like is there something else I can
do right I don't want to just hurtle
straight down the same yeah but I feel
like he hurdled down the straight line
first and then asked what to do rather
they're asking what to do before going
for A4 which is right there's a very
vast choice in this position after black
plays C6 he's down a minute I mean this
is where it starts right you spend a lot
of time in the opening and then
imperceptibly even if you play as fast
as your opponent in the middle game
you're off on the wrong foot but
literally he's in a position that he had
before right no this is unacceptable you
can't do that Hikaru is going to burn
you for this I mean there's very few
moves I know by heart and chess opening
Theory but I know this one because it
happened like 10 minutes ago and he
played Queen B1 in this position I think
rookie one appealed to me as well as a
different way of preparing E4 or maybe
Queen C2 yeah yeah I remember one minute
One Last Time Around
I mean I don't know what to say he's
just thinking maybe take on F6 another
idea you see in the Catalan is an
occasional Bishop takes F6 and then
maybe 95 okay he plays in 95 immediately
oh the dog outside did not like that
move
Hikaru has over three minutes Hikaru
liked it and sure I don't say this very
often David Hikaru is up two minutes in
a three minute game just repeat that
five times two minutes in a three minute
game two minutes in a three minute game
so he's that's a lot of time 100 of
ding's time here right exactly it's
about to get worse
he might actually be up three minutes in
the three minute game if he continues to
play instantly that's true it's fun I
think
he's new accomplishments now and then I
think ding needs to bail out ASAP and
basically make a draw which is exactly
what he's doing he's going to
temporarily win a pawn you know dc5 is
going to happen but I think your car is
going to surround it with his pieces and
ultimately pick it up yeah White's
Brooks are not in position to do
anything about this nope
and we're seeing it
yeah I mean Knight B3 for example is one
way to do it and Hikaru could even take
on C5 first and then bring his Queen
back second and yeah pick up the pick up
the Knight yeah also Knight B3 Queen F5
looks very
nice
threatening Queen D5 check
still up two minutes
yeah yeah ding trying to find a way to
cling to that pawn I think ding
understands that he can draw this
position
with a very limited time
yeah and he doesn't find anything yep
there's Queen F5
we have four Queen D5 Queen F3 is the
idea she's not blundering his Knight
now black could trade queens and take on
cf5 that's I'm sorry very safe but hey
Carlos probably tempted by ding's flag
here I'm thinking
I'm thinking he's very tempted by ding's
flag he's like is there some way you see
him yeah thinking about that all right
maybe I don't think so you kind of see
them on man there's nothing I can do
waving a red flag in front of a bull
right right
[Laughter]
oh that's an old old school technique
sometimes when your opponent has found a
Perpetual check
you basically wait until you it's a very
risky technique but you drop down to
five seconds and then you tempt him into
making a losing move but avoiding the
repetition so you bank on you know you
think you might have enough time to win
the game
yeah now confirm this for me Donya about
the setup can the players see each
other's cameras
I'm pretty sure they can yeah I'm 99
sure they can I think we've asked Anish
before I Niche that before and he said
they can yeah so hikar was really giving
ding a lot to look at right
well yeah it's like playing him over the
board you've got 20 seconds you're
getting ready for like a mad rush at the
end of the game and the other guy's got
three minutes so he just like makes you
watch like a little like facial
monologue for a minute
yeah I mean this is definitely the most
draws we've seen in the nscc match it's
gonna be another one
and um yeah I mean despite why it's
damaged spawn structure it doesn't
matter everything's defended the
accuracy is just off the charts here I
think oh yeah in these games like the
scent upon loss per move has got to be
really minimal well because but
partially yeah because they're going for
these simplified positions
and the chess.com insights page
has this interesting pattern where games
in the smooth shape tend to be higher
accuracy and that's not really
surprising when you think about it
because
these kinds of games enter into that
category where both players play well
and they play a simplified position
and Hikaru wins significantly more of
them which is also unsurprising because
he gets so many of them he's so good in
equal positions that was one of our
insights
I just had a you know had like a uh oh
moment for Hikaru for a second as he was
heading towards pretty much the worst
opening he's had all day today was in
this opening here he played C4 before E3
last time ding played foreign won the
game but other than that it was like
hikaru's worst worst experience I think
so far so here he played E3 instead yeah
and he's just he's just chilling in a
bad grunfelda's white yeah objectively
he's definitely worse here it's
interesting he's seeking out like you
said these bad reverse grinfelds yeah
right
yeah this is luxurious compared to the
other one yeah you know this is like a
five-star hotel but
I mean how does he can again he's got
the problem of not having moves like if
you go C4 ding
presumably answers with D4 so Hikaru
trying to trade some pieces Bishop A3 C5
and E4 carving out the C4 Square for his
Knight
making a square that's unpleasant for
black structure
indeed although it's still a lot of
space and C3 chipping away at blacks
Pawn chain
I mean
there's even a big question about D3
here right and ding says yeah
for sure
forces F3 because you don't want to let
that Bishop get into you too H5 he pokes
there with Knight H5 coming after H4
yeah this is
Lucario is seeking these positions out
with white another problem is that white
can't really get the Knight to D5 that
quickly because he's going to have to
reckon with the move D2 yeah that would
hurt a little you're like I'm gonna put
that on a good Square D2 oh yeah right
whoops well you're gonna get your knight
to D5 at least that's gonna be the
consolation I think your car might be
preparing that by the way you wanted
ding to play a bit more like
aggressively and see some more
aggressive chances how do you feel about
this game like I was just thinking about
three
yeah that's exactly what I was thinking
about I was going to praise him for for
the way he's played this game he has
gone straight after Hikaru in the
opening you know he's taking no
prisoners but like you said can he
finish these games off he has left
you know quite a few points on the table
already and this is another example of a
position that he should be able to win
if he's accurate oh yeah this position
especially after this last move why is
it so bad I guess Bishop F4 and just get
the queen around to H4 Maybe
yeah probably with trade and Rook d8
first to take the file
yeah but now his car is going to go Rook
D1 and start simplifying I guess ding
wants to put his Rook on D4 but right
then
slip away like they're always not quite
enough right I mean I would contemplate
taking I'm going still going Queen E7
hey Cara Michael Bishop B2 here
let's see
the knights covering Checkmate on H2 so
I don't even yet have like a plan for
winning here
well I mean it's some version of Bishop
H3 Knight G5 and going after F3 it is a
lot of moves though and it's time for
Hikaru to throw some water onto the fire
he goes Bishop C1
Here Comes ding ignores him
white is still a terrible shape here no
doubt about it I guess if you played
Bishop B2 ding went to carry would have
just left the Rook on D4 so hikar was
like why even attack The Rook if right
I'm not really going to take that hey
Cara let's just say it has not done a
lot to prevent Black's winning setup I
think we're gonna see Knight G5 and
we're gonna see Bishop H3 and ding's
just deciding on the order
in which to play them all right look at
White's position just look at it do you
make any micro predictions do you think
that Ding is going to win this game I
would be absolutely shocked this would
be one of the great come SCC comeback
individual game comebacks yeah if he I
mean nihal has is up on that list with a
couple of his games and so is sicaro of
course I've lost more winning positions
to hear car I'll put it that way
ding is also better than me at
converting advantages and everything
else so
Rook takes D1 and Bishop H3 is one
approach although you have to deal with
a check on d8
that ding's not getting this game up
this is also look at just leaving The
Rook on D4 I don't care yeah no I
assumed that The Rook was being left I
don't think any of this time was spent
on that it was just he was figuring
Bishop H3 or Knight H3 white is so why I
mean they're even Hikaru can't do
anything here this is just but I mean
why this was busted Rook D3 Bishop takes
F1
Bishop takes F1 is basically a thread G2
is a threat it's this is resignable when
it comes to squeezing a space Advantage
there's nothing better than when like
the king is at the end of the space
right like when you come down to the
first rank it's their King sitting there
all by itself
the car just did this variation on the
the hand waving the Magnus hand waving
it's just kind of sat back I don't know
just get this away from me yeah
yeah all right because sparov did that
too game levels the match
yeah it's tied it's six and a half six
and a half this is probably the most you
know the longest somebody has stayed
with icaro so far in the SEC
uh of course as you said this is just
the beginning you can't get up and say
I've made it because you have the bullet
coming up
I think ding has to deliver all the
white pieces here let's see it's an it's
a very popular Queen's Gambit line it
was very fashionable maybe two three
years ago not as much now yeah
hey Cara's very good at this line as
well I mean it seems like he's very very
well prepared with black like he's just
so comfortable playing the defensive
moves required neither player getting
any opening advantages with white and B5
what a bold move and what does he want
against B take C5
maybe Rook B1 and nope I guess it's not
that I guess we're about to find out he
takes on C5 ah maybe he wants to take on
C6 and go Knight A4 anyway so Cara plays
CB
okay what Rook V1 Knight D4 a lot of
possible moves here
I guess that wasn't the proper way but
he wants to win an exchange he wants to
take on B5 and go Knight C7 on the fork
but he's playing down a pawn for sure I
mean
Black's going to take on C5 here
yep
on back on B5
yeah and that's going to be the problem
after Rook A6 which you basically have
to play White delivers a fork on C7
um
Hikaru taking
pretty deep thing here trying to find a
way to stop that
all right this is uh this is quite
concerning of course white is also
threatening C6 with a fork yeah
wow
difficult moment for Hikaru
yeah
ding is bringing something and the car
is looking around for the answer
Bishop takes C5 is ultimately what he
settles on
and I was thinking at some point he can
play the move Pawn to E5 to slice The
Bishop's control of the C7 Square so
something like Knight B5 E5
and after Knight takes A7 he takes F4
he's gonna take on E3 and start just
basically destroying White's Pawn cover
I actually think that's a pretty serious
problem and my necessity ding taking
with the other night I don't know how
that impacts this sequence I guess the
Knight on D4 will act as a shield
against the Bishops uh right then but
then you're just forked and black
recaptures on A7
yeah but the thing is after E5 maybe you
can play Bishop to ac5
okay okay okay and then Bishop takes D4
and you get a mass liquidation which
results in a material imbalance where
we'll cross that bridge if we get there
yeah
figure out what he thinks the bridge is
he's hesitating before Crossing it you
know it's funny car uh caruanas your
car's uh handle on ICC for many years
was Capilano Bridge which I think is a
bridge in Vancouver where Hikaru used to
live
it's one of those suspended bridges that
you know you kind of have to
whatever your religious sign is you do
it before Crossing it oh yeah I would
never go across those movie Bridges
those exist in in real life oh yeah I I
actually visited uh with some friends a
couple months ago Grandfather Mountain
and it's in North Carolina
uh it's in the Appalachian Mountains and
there was such a there was one of those
bridges that was just completely
transparent it was swinging oh there
were people standing there taking
selfies you know talking about the
meaning of life I was like I am I ran
across it and I was just praise the
entire way but you did cross it I did
cross it yeah I crossed it twice there
in the back I felt like I had to I mean
my friends seemed completely unconcerned
yeah I don't I don't care about about my
friends being unconcerned right exactly
Bridge
in the meantime to be the one so they
went down that night seat takes before
but instead of going E5 your car took
the Knight forcing ding away from
I mean he had a fork here but I guess
there's Knight C6 or Brooke if you
wanted something like that anyways wow
Hikaru has avoided the worst of this I
think it just now has a big time just
keeping the extra Pawn
foreign
for now
Rook C1 ding has clear compensation in
the form of Peace activity Knight b5s
maybe Knight C6 go after the a pawn I
don't know but he's got 30 seconds I
feel like your compensation kind can
kind of slip away when you're low on
time for sure
uh if Hikaru can find the right time to
play E5 you know and you can be in
trouble
right he plays E5 there forcing the
bishop back
then we're gonna get queen beat eight
a four is fine I don't know bike is
still a bit awkward yeah white wants
also Queen C2 and infiltrate the eighth
rank the car down to a minute himself
this is I would definitely this is like
standing on the bridge if you're black
here okay A4 oh so he stops white from
going A4 now the Knight is a little bit
less less angle man I'm giving him X
lamps for that that was nice but ding's
still preserving
for the moment domination maybe Rook B
yeah but then you'd lose A4 yeah he knew
he was gonna just have to come back
passively with Rook A8 but he just he
just knew he couldn't let that Knight be
defended yeah um which would no that was
a white full position it was a good
decision but he's struggling to follow
it up G5 what a bold move weakening the
king but getting the bishop away from H4
and ding in activates his Queen's coming
in Knight D6 there's maybe Rook B6 uh
hey 20 seconds for ding as he drops back
to C3 hitting the D5 Pawn yikes Queen E6
maybe Queen E6 defending everything
although I guess then white will take A4
except day for you the double x Glam
Pawn on A4 now whoa
what a move Queen takes C6 you play 97
check and pick up the queen at the end
of that though black single either Rook
B3 or Rook B1 Rook C1 yes and you're
gonna be in trouble
of course instantly and if rookie sees
everything Rook C8 there's Knight B6
You're Gonna Lose the Knight
probably uh oh dang with five seconds
how do you save the night
F3 Knight you have to take on B8 and
give up the exchange and then Bishop E5
covers Rook C3 as well at least still
still some danger for black there's pins
Galore white has good drawing chances
here but I didn't save this with two
seconds wow he gives the F7 pawn and he
doesn't take it he wants the a pawn
that's the pawn what has to capture
the car was like nope
and then maybe Hikaru can try to get his
Knight somewhere a little bit more
active
Knight f8 96 something like that yep
Knight B8 nice C6 situations desperate
for white I mean
yeah I don't see things saving this in
the long run this is like that end game
the pawn you can get rather than the
pawn you want but can't get okay so he's
gotten the a pawn which is the good news
the bad news for white is that there's
been a trade of minor pieces can hikara
win this end game
King F5
I think you can play King F5 here king
of five he's got no time he's got two
seconds
he wants Knight D6 and then Knight F5
and then going after the H1
good Primo
yeah
but hey Carl will play Rook F4 I think
yeah oh King he's six he's just taking
all of Black's Pawns
amazing technique
wow with two seconds on the clock ding
is making Hikaru shake his head yeah now
actually black can be in a little bit of
danger here yeah before age six I mean
it's anybody's game oh my God's covering
both squares the king would need to like
go after those pawns yeah King James
he had to take the pawn on D7 and give
his Jeep on for the H1 how does Sting
win this oh my God that dick blunters in
the way I didn't see a win I didn't see
it either I think he had to play Queen
D7 Queen D7 setting up a discovery and I
think the game's gonna end in a draw
after all this is going to be saved by
ding this is a very easy end game to
draw wow oh my goodness what a crazy
turn now let me very quickly man let me
open that game I don't think Hikaru saw
96 but oh my goodness what a position
thing is no checks and what he had to do
David is go Queen D7 that was the move
but how did you even find that 10
seconds later well it's just because I I
solved a lot of studies like this and
the point is that you give the discovery
yeah there's mate here
and here you have to work a little bit
harder but I mean there's a knight F7
Knight G5 and if King G8 then there's
Queen E8 and queen h8 I'm pretty sure
that that was the technique but how hard
is that to find in two seconds
long story short it's a draw and the
match is tied at seven a piece as we go
into our mid segment break David this
matches
you know added somebody's added some
Tabasco sauce here because loving those
end games absolutely these games have
been so interesting the match has been
close seat belts fastened we're gonna go
on a short break and when we come back
we will have the second part of the
three minute portion you're watching the
speed Chess Championship presented by
coinbase we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is fast approaching you certainly don't
want to miss your chance to stock up
with some new chess.com merch head on
over to go.chess.com merch and check out
some Nifty sweatshirts and all manner of
clothing so you can be all ready to
display your chest outcome swag in front
of your family at the New Year Gathering
David
we hope the whole family is gathered
around the computer screen to watch this
SCC semifinal because it has been an
epic one thus far the score is 7-7 we've
got 30 minutes of three plus one left
yeah
um 30 minutes three plus one and then 30
minutes of one plus one so
um half an hour left here
um for dingley rent try and get a little
Advantage before he goes into the bullet
where Hikaru is
um you know a scary a scary bullet
figure in the world so yep just a tad
and the smart smart chess prediction
gave a two-point advantage to Hikaru on
the three plus one so far that's not
really bearing out but you know I can
see where that prediction is coming from
but it is also predicting a six and a
half two and a half one plus one score
which is not very reassuring for ding
fans right he has to have at least a
two-point lead that was what I said kind
of before the match I stand by that dig
needs a very very strong finish to the
three plus one segment yeah smarter
chess was dead on about the five minute
section five to four but at the moment
ding has good chances to beat the
prediction for the 3-1 section
um
although you know you only get so many
chances against Chicago that that nearly
impossible to find study like when just
now maybe that's the kind of thing you
need to find with two seconds on your
clock again and again if you want to get
a lead against zacaro it would be crazy
if your car actually saw Knight D6 and
went for that line consciously and found
it in one second that would be an
interesting question to ask of him I the
thing is I would rule that out with
anybody else but with Hikaru I actually
could see him
could see him finding that having seen
that wow
yeah
Okay so
yeah the games are about to begin
and let me see if I can pull that up
yeah oh there we go they should already
be playing here yep we have another one
of these
nimso Indian e kind of structures this
time he car has positioned his pawns on
B4 and D4 yeah exactly what you said
last time around in this position
Upon A B4 and he's not going to be
allowing C5 C4 for ding here
um another difference this is Bishops on
G2 that other
game with this structure White's Bishop
was on D3 oh yeah I think yukaro has fan
cuttered his Bishops in virtually every
game yeah almost all of them oh here's
another freaking move yeah I like it
that's that's the kind of style I want
to see digging playing in yeah
well now I mean he's just gonna trade
and play H4 here right or one would
imagine H4 immediately he said he's not
worried about a car taking because his
Pawn on e4 is kind of going to clog up
the center
and then you can put a bishop on B5 yeah
I mean it allows white to play D5 and
open up the B2 Bishop but
um I suppose he doesn't think White's
ready to attack upon with D5 and he just
rushes forward with the H Pawn Hikaru
Knight D2 to F3 when ding obviously
wanted to play H4 is not good news and
now the a trial has opened now the
question it's up for grabs can black get
a rook to h8 quickly he could that
Classic Plan is G6 King G7 Rook h8 yeah
there are issues with that plan though
because you your King's gonna be in the
well I cannot draw this arrow in the
path of the diagonal white can park the
Knight on E5 so yeah I don't think it's
as simple as as it may seem here yeah
you might want to play F6 here first and
then work on that plan but ding says
have E5 I've got a plan right
wow Rook H6 that's how he chooses to get
the Rook to the to the eighth rank or to
the H file rather yeah so he's saying
that you know even with the Knight on E5
even with the weakness on C6 there is
not concretely a way for Hikaru to open
up any part of the center here that's
his and my car going Bishop F3 I think
he was preparing King G2
Rook H uh Rook H1 now he's basically
saying okay I'm going back but you can't
go Rook H6 because F5 is gonna hang and
another repetition is ding gonna go for
it a minute down on the clock I think he
probably will
no he won't he waited for me to say that
yeah I was thinking he's not he's not
going to take that repetition Carl's
like you know gut checking him saying
like you know did we just make a bunch
of draws and ding has to say you know I
think I'm better
yeah I mean he he knows that the time in
the three minute segment is dwindling I
think ding understands that if there's a
time to take risks then it is now
yeah and you know if Hikaru plays King
G2 then Knight G5 might be a lot more
harder to deal with because you can't
drop the bishop back on this diagonal
and if you bring it back to E2 well then
ding's going to take on E5 and go
default check with pretty devastating
consequences he's talking to you too
though he's gone King G2
let's see if it ends up playing Knight
G5 or maybe even taking on E5 first yep
there it is
yeah
and I wonder what you call us plan here
because taking on F5 looks a little bit
too crazy six here
he didn't try it he tried something else
I was thinking Knight C6 might might
have like dealt with the problem by
attacking wait a second I'm in the queen
I think ding can take on E5 I think ding
could have taken 95 and met Bishop takes
D5 with Queen F7
I also think he's made another great
movie Cars position is totally falling
apart here because ding is threatening
to take take and then go D4 check and
win White's Queen
yeah this is a winning also he's
threatening to bring the Rook on A8 you
know into the game and then do that
thing like White's quite tied up here as
far as being able to
move out of the way of this maybe
how bad is it if you Retreat the Knight
since the night is the way that black
opens the bishop on B7 like if you play
Knight D3 you might the problem might
not even be Knight take step three it
might be Rook H2 check right and then
Queen H6 before taking the bishop or or
even taking the bishop on Queen E4 I
think there's multiple paths here okay
picaro has gone Knight D3 I think Rook
H2 check ends the game
now ding has to see these moves he plays
F4 instead which is also refreshing I
think it has a pretty good threat yep
that does seem pretty snazzy as well
um Rook H1
yeah then takes and takes after your car
just resigns wow I mean there are no
moves there you're getting crushed yeah
you're not jumping out to a one point
lead with 20 minutes left in the three
plus one
that game was crushing
and I wonder yeah I wonder if black has
a plus score in this match like white
has gotten
really not good positions in general
yeah I mean it's it's kind of weird
because any car just hasn't played very
ambitiously ding has played his main
repertoire but as you've said icaro has
been extremely well prepared
uh against Sting's main Suite of
openings and this time didn't going for
C6 I think he's he either looked this up
during the break or he's just improving
on it in his mind wait is this C6 this
time is this how he played last time I
guess it is he's gonna go Knight D4
Knight B5 it sometimes this is different
it's sort of transposing last game he'd
played Knight D4 Bishop C5 Knight B5 no
but look but the evil bar here is like
very much in White's favor yeah
and something about this position is
different didn't
maybe not anyway it doesn't matter let's
see how ding plays from this yeah yeah
it is different he didn't play C6 he
played Knight D4 black took on C5 with
the bishop then he took on Beats oh okay
so that was the difference like so C6
was an improvement that he like came up
with yeah but here's the problem black
plays E5 the Knight takes eight Rook
takes it and Knight F5 counter-attacking
the bishop at least or Knight C6 or
Knight C6 there or even Knight C6 yeah
is is shaking here and he's in big
trouble in this game as well
Rook B1 is also a problem
yeah
and this and the smarter chess Aussie
predictions right above the player's
heads that you all can see right now are
suddenly I mean that's how close the
match is at this one game has got these
two bars sort of like just suddenly
coming straight close to 50 50 from a
match which was generally favored almost
75-25 for Hikaru before the match
started that one crushing win with black
and
yeah and Hikaru shaking his head here is
the queen almost trapped
um by Knight B5 both Rooks attacked it's
a position where it's hard not to resign
even and
that's what he chooses to do he plays a
move and then just resigns before uh
before ding can can eat up all the Rooks
and here's our first E4 of the match
Hikaru
feels some pressure and goes for a
change switches things up he has been
getting very bad positions with white so
I think this might be worth doing here I
mean overall he's playing great I just
think the positions with white out of
the opening are not good thing we ran to
a two-point lead and the odds prediction
finally we see the Purple Line crossing
the yellow line for the first time all
day today all right
so looking at the position that we've
got out of the opening is hikaru's
position better than
with the other openings he's used yes
he's got a C6 Square for a knight he's
got a queen on F3 which is going to
cover the whole board pretty nicely
and on this position is uh much more
interesting to play for white I think
than some of the other ones he's had
yeah I mean this is a very old school
line it's been around for a while this
A4 D4 stuff
and there's a clear upside and downside
to this the upside is that why it has
this you know amazing night on C6 the
downside
and now hikara has an extra Pawn this
Pawn on F4 is sticking out like a sore
thumb White's King is going to be
permanently a little bit weak at these
positions
and uh the F4 Pawn is a little bit yucky
and as is the D5 font now ding is
threatening A5
right and so if white plays Knight C6
the plan is to just take on D5
so white needs to support that structure
C4 could be played but it leaves B2
really really weak right since the
bishop on F6 can't be blocked off
anymore and Rook B8 is coming right and
Jenny is playing so confidently he's
playing faster now he senses the moment
yeah and he needs to strike as many
times as he can in these last 15 minutes
yeah
I mean if he could win three or four
games in a row here closing out the 3-1
section you know just like Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam right oh yeah you rarely see
that in one of hikaru's matches yeah and
one idea here would be to go Rook B8 and
do C6 and then go Knight C5 and head for
B3 okay this is exactly what he does oh
man
okay
um what to do now though it brings the
screen back defending the B3 square and
keeping the defense of the D5 Pawn Yeah
black needs another lever to pull but I
don't see it he decides to just prevent
Bishop E3 for the moment to slow down
hikaru's untangling but but now that
was a terrible move
dang blundered that and I think even
takes in G5 with traffic
and that's the deflating thing about
playing guitar you feel like you just
mounted the Run of your life and you're
up at one point yeah
okay this is also very good the knight's
coming back to C6 then B4 huh here nope
he went for the more the safer but
perhaps simpler option
yeah it is pretty safe I mean here like
the Knight on B4 is just doing
everything it needs to right it's like
fighting successfully against three
black pieces unbelievable totally
limiting everything and now it's
rightful reward is to emerge back on C6
ding trying desperately to change the
course of the match maybe he'll throw in
a check on D4 with shikaru blundered
there
that's a great question I think it was G
takes F6 to just take it some sort of
Queen yeah Knight C6 it's just a hard
move to play like all of a sudden to
realize that you need to sack The
Exchange has tremendous activity now
wait a second this one's not over dig
might pull a rabbit out of the hat for
once yeah he was so close to winning the
game safely so to speak for white and
yeah
foreign
has just been so good in the openings
you rarely see him in a bad position
she's like he hasn't had a chance even
to come back yeah
now let's see if he can complete a
knight D3 I think he needs the E file
here
he agrees
and basically Knight takes C5 or dc5
both moves are possible here yeah Knight
takes C5 Bishop E3 94.
uh trying to isolate that D5 Pawn
and right white plays Rook D1 you've got
Queen B2 so it's it's not easy for white
to defend everything here because like
A5 D5 B2 like there's so many different
loose spots
what worries me about
what worries me about ding is that once
you get into the bullet he's just not
going to be able to take this amount of
time in critical moments yeah will he be
able to adapt to playing intuitively and
look at it Queen B5 not moving the
Knight aiming for the E2 Square yeah
he's dominating this game as well Bishop
B3
is the idea here for black but it would
have rookie won and then Black's gonna
have back ring problems 94 Bishop D4
yeah black is gonna have that was a very
impulsive move by ding Knight A4 and if
you take on C3
there's gonna be something like Bishop
F2 and here's the problem at the very
end of this line white is going to break
through with B5 and win the game with a
past day pawn
and I think Dane just completely
underestimated that and he wiggle his
way out of this just like running out of
time in response too no I don't see him
I think Queen D3 is such a tempting move
but it allows rookie one creating a
standoff between the Rooks and that
favors White
ding with a few too many mistakes this
game
yeah and I see why my knight A4 move
doesn't work white just plays Bishop F2
and
after Queen's trade The Rook on E8 is
hanging so we can't get the C Pawn
yep digging down to 10 seconds he does
take on C3 and I think we are precisely
going to see Bishop F2
and end game and a breakthrough with B5
isn't going to win hikar of the game
yeah
I mean even after Knight T3 it could
play B5 you could you could premium B5
they might try Knight D7 Knight B8
yeah
oh he currently playing Bishops for
Bishop to A7 oh the point is B5 yeah it
might be a bishop A7 very very precise
yeah not giving ding any additional
chances and a big big win for Nakamura
here
that was a nice one
just what he needed just what he needed
there we'll see again after that a lot
more adventurous in the opening already
and I really think he's trying to turn
this match around before the bull he
doesn't want
you know he doesn't want to even think
about having to
you know having to undo a lead
as they get into the blood and this this
is transposed into a queen's Indian
with ding playing A3 that's definitely a
very
popular line in G6 with a double field
Kettle now with the black pieces
yeah
we can see two and E4 the most ambitious
kind of weapon by ding who claims the
entire Center were those pawns yeah
I mean I love this position for white
especially after E5 D5 blocking out that
Bishop on B7
and well basically King's Indian now
Dania where black has uh played
Bishop yeah
B6 is fairly rare and even if you play
B6 you never play Bishop B7 but yeah
that's even rare but other than that
it's super close to just being a king's
Indian which Hikaru oh yeah fantastic
player of exactly and that was at one
point in over the board in his over the
worker that was one of his main weapons
now C6 you see even more rarely than
that it gives white the D5 score no no
question that Ding is better here
but these structures can be it can be
very hard once again to deliver the
crushing blow you're better you have a
space Advantage but how do you actually
proceed
yeah
yeah and her car is just going to be
like very very comfortable he's going to
know very very easily what he wants to
do
yeah very fast yeah Knight f8 96 Rook
ACA Plex plays quite straightforward
that is a paradox of these positions
where black is worse but one could say
black has an easier job making moves
which is why you often want to go for
these lines of Blitz
yeah yes sometimes the position that's
kind of restricted you only have one
piece you can move so it's very easy to
to move it Knight D5 Queen E8 just
keeping the tension he doesn't really
mind this Knight on D5
let's see whether Jin can increase the
pressure I like B5 he wants to play A4
and A5
and create big problems on Black's Queen
side although he does give away the C5
Square
yeah and there is a knight coming there
in a moment
foreign
how will Hikaru deal with this
well it doesn't look like there's any
move that stops A5 right now
if it's gonna come in time before then
it comes to C5 and now if Knight C5 the
pawn on B6 would be hanging
yeah everything is saying A4 there's
Knight A5
this is very nice if you just choose
Knight V3 over Bishop takes A7
yeah he did
you might be asking why huge opportunity
to turn the beep on into a pass well I
think he's gonna take both of them if he
doesn't take a seven now I'm gonna be
shocked he does yeah yeah okay he
and again he's crushing just looked
ahead that he would get everything
how does he untangle his Queen side but
does he even need to untangles queen
size or does he just say all right I'm
pushing
full steam ahead
and leave the bishop on A7
yeah hikar was chosen a very tricky
defensive approach he's given away both
Pawns
but it's almost like he's trapped twice
minor pieces on the queen side where
they don't really have a lot of prospect
ding trying to get a knight to C6
Chicago could try to beat him to the
punch with Knight T4 he does
yeah will we see an exchange say no I
don't think so I don't think so it would
let G7 out too oh yeah no I
categorically against that Bishop takes
D5
if this is what he wanted to do this was
better last move I think without night
before
bedtime's hesitating about what to do
yeah he's trading a bunch of pieces I
don't really know who that
favors entirely
technically white should still be
winning by a margin here but
you know we all know that doesn't mean
very much when you're playing Hikaru one
more game after this one is very likely
yeah with six minutes remaining and
two very important games very very
important if yakaro can tie the match
they'll be thrilled if Dink and open up
a two or three point lead that's really
all that he can ask for that positions
him pretty well going into the bullet
yeah man I'm looking forward to this
bullet set I'm really looking forward to
seeing what happens yeah it's going to
be so much more exciting with uh with
having maybe a one-point lead
um it really is
now can ding finish the effort I think
Cairo has found a way to activate that
King's Indian Bishop but it has come at
the cost of another Pawn yep two pawns
huge pressure on F2 ding hesitating a
long time about which way to take there
it takes with the epon ultimately
opening up a Channel of negotiations
between the Rooks and I don't know who
benefits a fall Rockstar traded because
guess what black has this incredible
blockade on both of White's extra pawns
it is a great question if you just took
all the Rooks off the board
would the queen be enough to win a
position which would be a dead draw with
just Bishops yeah if the Queens are
traded even with two extra pawns as many
people know that that doesn't really
mean anything and obviously colored
Bishop end games
I'm inclined to say that Hikaru is gonna
hold this position I I just don't see
how dig makes progress if he can't play
B6 and Hikaru will make sure of that
then I don't see it
well he's looking to play the middle
game on the king side like The Bishop's
been committed to to the blockade and
now he wants to go attack on the king
side I think he's thinking of like G4
right now
and I think you should play it the evil
bar
hated Queen A8
yeah I I think oh G4 K2 was the idea
infiltrating to F6 first now for K2 he
wants Rook F4
maybe G4 now
just go G4 start it start the attack
yeah I mean black can hardly move like
on Queen G7 you just go to the eighth
rank so yeah and rookie two probably has
to be played at this point but then
simply Rook F4
and H5 is coming in your king side
Bishop takes G6 is a massive threat
that's the huge threat so Queen G7 might
be forced now then yeah maybe Queen EA
play Queen E7
Queen G7 I agree check
maybe Queen I fade in that position but
then there's a trade and Bishop takes G6
comes
I don't know if I see this happening for
hikar this might be another win for ding
and he just almost effortlessly managed
to create now Bishop takes G6 oh Bishop
G6 there's Queen E6 check has to yeah
that
and why did he do this
on G6 without bringing the keys the
worst version of the end of that is
terrible terrible transition now and
Hikaru is gonna win the F2 pawn and make
it drop
that's shocking that was outrageous what
was Queen takes G7 you could just take
the pawn immediately yeah I I wait I
don't know yeah I don't know I mean
that's a one that's a below I am level
blown opportunity
and this was a pivotal moment because he
could have jumped up two-point
guaranteed himself a lead going to the
bullet now car draws this game he gets a
white game in the last one if he wins it
you don't have anything to show for it
now wait a second still a little tricky
but no it's a try
that was another one of the most amazing
not wins that I've seen
The Botch brilliancy ding completely out
playing Hikaru in that game basically
from the opening
and as it stands and you know hikara
might even want to wipe the rest of the
time off of the match block here and say
I'm happy with a one-point deficit
yeah or maybe ding wants to do that I
don't know okay anyways they make a draw
make a draw and this is a crucial game
and here comes absolutely
absolutely crucial it's a Ry Lopez icaro
has switched to E4 back to even playing
hikaru's weapon playing the Berlin he's
got 100 score with money for so far in
this match but most of all some of those
double fiancado positions he got were I
mean like actively bad like and I don't
see him doing that in the bullet like I
don't ever see Hikaru playing that
passively in the bullet the last straw
was that game where where ding played H5
H4 and just yeah no that was just lifted
The Rook
okay so Hikaru is generally on the black
side of these positions with the move D5
here he's on the white side it's very
symmetrical it's really often a battle
of Maneuvers and squares you know white
trash together Knight to F5 and black
tries to get is Knight to F4 sometimes
it's a pretty slow moving game
yeah
and apparently there was some
controversy recently about whether the
Knight on C6 is slightly bad or not in
these positions
um
yeah that is a slightly unconventional
recapture away from the center but you
can see why he's done it oh yeah the
bishop on B2 and The Rook on C1 are
celebrating that that decision black is
uncomfortable here
why because seriously uncomfortable I
mean you can't really go Knight V8 you
give up maybe you can
but you have to deal with Knight takes
C5 if you don't white wants to take on
C6 if you play Bishop D7 you let the
other Knight get into the game
yeah it's a lot of pressure
it's a lot of pressure well at least
Bishop D7 maybe threatens Knight takes
B4 so it's not so simple
um
yeah somehow you need to overprotect E5
and untangle one of these not the
knights are both actually struggling
right now
okay goes for Bishop D7 I guess Knight
Knight C4 there's Knight takes B4 so you
can do that immediately yeah
yeah he carved definitely with an edge
out of the opening he might have to move
his Bishop back yep there it is
okay clearing the way for Knight C4
ramping up not sure Knight D4 looks like
an interesting try to to change up the
position because there's even some
Bishop A4 ideas in the end of that line
right which could help black a little
bit and that's exactly the kind of thing
black needs is is the right moment to
play something like that and ding seizes
it Bravo yep love Knight D4 and Bishop
A4 intermed so wow
he plays it right off the bat you can
like that every blow that lands on
Hikaru it's like physically painful oh
yeah
ouch
now why can't he take over the Rook on
D4 maybe he can
I don't see off the top of my head what
ding has in mind I guess we'll find out
um
um there could be Bishop
E3 Queen B3 Bishop H2 King H2 Rook D4
Knight D4 Queen E5 uh amazing find
amazing fun let me show that on the
board Rook if Rook takes D4 then he
takes one Knight takes the pawn on H2
takes the rook and then at the end Forks
the Knight the king that might be one of
the options Hikaru playing E5 E5 this is
rookie one
yeah how does black untangle himself
from the pin well one I mean Black's got
a number of moves to look at here from
like Queen E6 to D3 D7 doesn't make
sense I mean defending the bishop brings
his own Bishop just defends it okay so
now you do queen F6
he plays it now he can move the bishop
away he can play Bishop F4 and Knight E5
for example if he wants
yeah
Knight B6 also
is an idea hunting White's Bishop a
little Tempo on C1 over protecting three
that's not a movie make if you really
like your position I like Knight B6 I
feel like that's a little more ambitious
than Knight E5
I think you should play it you could
also go C6 and try to go B5
yeah I was looking at C5 here
right and if Knight takes C5
yeah
it doesn't quite yeah B6 it goes every
different than anything we recommended
like not quite the same it's like a
cross between our two moves
so now White's gotta take on D4 probably
before you play C5 or I mean yeah a few
places like what does thing have in mind
well Knight D4 if Knight ft4 he has 95
if Knight he takes E4 he might have
still Knight E5 might have still 95 yeah
Lucario plays Bishop B5 what kind of a
weird game ding is definitely better
here but he's got 30 seconds yeah 30
seconds he's been here
I don't know if he's ever won the game
when he was this low on time
hmm
Knight f8 is a nice move laying down the
wood here he wants the Knight back on E6
yeah where it's gonna fully support the
D4 upon he's gonna keep his extra Pawn
here Hikaru trying to create counter
play with his own past spawn
E3
I think all that time to protect the
pawn on D4 and then it just goes yeah
and then it's just shot forward yeah I
guess he wants his Queen to infiltrate
C3 with shikaru does not which with his
last move and it's on D2
where it's like the least offended that
pawn went really far really fast
things playing very dynamically I don't
know how you make these calculations
with 20 seconds
it served him very well his intuition is
so good he's very very accurate the car
takes the pawn it wasn't a poison Pawn
I guess we're about to find out we need
to the rook's double is the idea and
then Queen has to come
huddle up where does it go Queen's can't
allow Queen's three I think so it'll go
to C2 oh but then there's like before
but the thing is 46
which ding had calculated Bishop takes
D2 was played out of a cannon he gives
up the bishop but he's going to take the
a pawn he's still going to be a pawn up
at the end
holding on D2 he's just cleaning up the
a pawn right now he's got winning
chances but yeah I mean he car is
probably not unhappy with this type of
position which he can definitely defend
yeah yeah he's H George defense wow
actively 30 30 seconds for Nakamura
he goes G3 creating Luft it's a tough
position
yeah they're gonna transition into an
end game and this is really hard to
defend I feel like in classical black
will be closer to a win than white to a
draw
for sure 96.
yeah Knight end game down upon
ding's gonna get his own King into the
center
can he win this crucial game and go up
by two going into the bullet nice
careful move C6 I like it I practice
this end game against the computer a lot
too and I never win it but at least I
feel like it's so easy to create a
password the wrong moment like at the
worst moment when your opponent easily
wins it so like don't go see five here
five is an idea
oh he's gonna take on B4
oh if Hikaru had defended that with his
Knight he would have taken up before
anyone forced a pawn end game ding is
making big progress here
yeah yeah this is doing very well for
Blackstone coming to D4
ikaro positioning his own Knight to
deliver maximum checks yeah the famous
repetition
Pawn trade is on different deck here
enough
the car holding him back for the time
being he might even put a king on before
yeah
this is so close to a wind and so close
to a draw at the same time yeah yeah
once it's impossible
the car is doing a great job so far ding
has not made progress in a while
he's got to get his Knight to a
different Square
more checks
uh-oh King D6 it's gonna be a repetition
okay there it is yeah he can back up but
King centralizes 1995 but it's not gonna
help yeah I don't see the thing really
winning this now but now I do now I do
it yeah
well it went back to F2 to win the win
the blacks pawns and that that's not
gonna cut it now not F2 and King E4 yeah
now Hikaru is like unbeatable in this
position it's like he will never make
any obvious mistakes amazing that takes
G4 Knight takes G4
yeah double tracks
yep triple checks and there it is if
b395 B2 Knight C4 check that's what big
big big save for Hikaru and he can deal
with a one point deficit because he can
wipe that out on the very first game of
the bullet still this is the closest
we've seen a hikara mesh in a long time
all props to ding for an excellently
conducted three-minute session
he jumps out to one point lead David
this is gonna come down literally to the
wire to the last segment
well we're going to let the players
prepare for this bullet time to not go
anywhere cancel your evening plans these
30 minutes
from the fast Mouse to their really fast
Mouse indeed indeed we'll let the
players do that you're watching the
speed Chess Championship presented by
coinbase we'll be back with a bullet in
the field
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
how many brilliant moves have you played
when do you play your best chess
how many games have you won by castling
in the end game
how many opponents have you played from
New Zealand
and most importantly of all how many
botes gambits has Alexandra botez played
find the answers to all of these
questions and many many more at
chess.com insights
our new tool that lets you dive deep
into all of the fun and instructive data
behind your chest try it today
welcome back to the SEC make sure to
check out your own insights at chess.com
insights let's revisit the insights from
the ding Hikaru match that we talked
about in the beginning ding with a
slightly higher accuracy over Nakamura
that has borne out so far in the match
uh hikara with a much higher win
percentage in the end game I think we
might see some of that in the bullet As
Time scrambles are going to be become
more common and David Hikaru wins
significantly more smooth games but I
think ding is such a great technical
player that some of these even games
have not necessarily gone hikaru's way
so far in the match no but what I was
just thinking during the breakdonya was
I was wondering in my head like has ding
won an end game yet today he's had a lot
of good positions but the games that I
remember him winning were almost all
like he managed to land a knockout blow
in the middle game I can't think of an
end game that he converted to a win
right now
yeah I think Hikaru could probably write
a book on defending Pawn down end games
that's like a very specific category
where your car seems to be virtually
unbeatable and we saw that play out in
the last game where ding had excellent
winning chances in this night end game
and here we go
the bullet has begun and I think a lot
is going to be revealed in the first
couple of games we're going to see if
ding can adapt speed wise
yeah we're gonna see if Hikaru just
dominates which is definitely a
possibility but ding has been you know a
lot of people haven't expected him to
hang with the car like this and let's
not forget he's already won two SEC
matches so he knows what he's doing yeah
Hikaru is varying his opening he's
putting a rook on C8 to deal with his B5
C6 breakthrough right away so he's not
repeating
uh something that Ding is familiar with
from the three-minute portion it looks
like they're playing 10 second chess the
speed they both have over a minute yeah
yeah great speed from ding
and I think the first question is just
like how many games will it take for
ding to win his first bullet game like
if he wins his first bullet game within
like let's say two games that's gonna
tell him that you know he can win this
match
um yeah
a lot of players when they face the car
they just get blown out the first two or
three games and then they just it's not
that they tilt per se it's just that
they lose confidence they think yeah
this guy's a bullet bullet Beast there's
just no way I'm winning a single game
and the match spirals out of control so
it's very important to start off on a
good note
okay so so far I think ding has the
position he wants he's better that pawn
on C6 is a permanent weakness which
white can try to attack and he's getting
his Knight around to D3
so fast that he got to take a deep think
about the nitrate on e4
yeah but how is he gonna make progress
that I really don't see I in the
position is so locked up the black queen
on B7 is supervising the pawn on C6 I
just don't see it happening
yeah although a draw is not the end of
the world of course
no no it drives no problem I mean if if
you don't see a way to win rather go
Queen A3 Queen A2 Queen really quickly
and uh not risk anything yeah but Knight
F4 just wins upon another oversight by
day and that is really basic you've got
to see the two hanging pawns jeez
he's leaving those types of moves on the
table aren't they I just don't
understand back to G1 what
neither player
I mean I just it takes a metaphor yeah
now Knight A5 I think or queen A5 he's
got to make some aggressive moves here
there it is okay so now he's probably
threatening Queen B6 because that like
that B Pawn would be so awkward for
White's Knights oh yeah I just don't see
it with a defend against Queen B6 in
fact yeah there's no pieces over there
this is horrible for black and black is
losing this might be the first end game
dig wins if the knife from F7 moves to
d8
yeah then whitesnite immediately swoops
into E5 I would imagine no dink playing
queen bees I don't know if I like that
move knight move five put a knight on E5
oh I think it's good knight C5 and he's
gonna Force the car to give up a piece
or not is the car we're gonna hold this
oh my God that means he's holding it
what is going on H4 is a bad sign that
means you have you're trying to open up
a second flank yeah I mean how is he
actually gonna make that happen just
can't push a car over the edge amazing
and somehow your car stopped the pawn
which I thought was impossible yeah and
I think well it's not over yet then can
try G4 you can try to keep breaking
through
oh
it looks like war is gone for a moment
G4 absolutely everything
now wait Knight d395 becomes a serious
possibility
yeah I mean that's where the Knight
could have gone to begin with
yeah but now
Knight C4 yeah Hikaru is playing this
perfectly by the way wow he is not
giving a single chance and here comes
the night back from D3 I think he's
going around to E5
this bullet game has already taken four
minutes off the clock a why yeah why
that'll still be just one piece wait a
second 96 a car was giving up the g-pawn
why did he why did he go to B7 with his
King that was this very surprising
decision now dig is winning again
oh it looks you can just super super oh
I don't like G6 well he left black
blockade him
Knight he should throw in Knight G4
maybe it's oh he just walks his King
around where is he going
how is he gonna get there I don't know I
can't keep five minutes
progress I think car is still not giving
up
oh didn't give up a pawn but okay 1949
F6
95. looks like he may have 94. still not
over and now it's finally over and Ting
wins the first bullet game he wins all
the games and he wins an end game and
five minutes off the match clock and you
gotta believe that there is a chance for
ding oh there's absolutely win this
entire match
there is absolutely a chance I think he
played very fast in the opening his time
management was Exquisite he never really
went down below 10 seconds
yeah he's playing this like a bullet Pro
and I just think I think it's a lot of
it is confidence I honestly think ding
is sensing that this matches I wouldn't
say up for grabs but he's sensing that
he can do it he's up by two
and he continues to play very fast here
in the opening yeah he's just not
feeling that invulnerability yeah from
Hikaru
which Hikaru is so good at producing
like he makes you feel like you're not
gonna win a game yeah and as you said
when you break the seal this early you
know the facts kind of fly in the face
of that
so I mean everybody's enjoying this
except Hikaru everybody else even Hikaru
fans like to see like a close match like
to see him challenged I think a lot of
them but not on the worst side of
Oklahoma actually like to see a car up
by one or two
oh it's more exciting for them to see
him like make a comeback here and bullet
that is definitely true as well
and again I think he's they've got a
complicated Kings Indian attack I don't
think white is better White's got the
pressure on a on A5
and he's got his car's got 20 seconds
extra I feel like that's gonna costing
in the long run the position remains
very complex
okay yeah what does black do
improve the first step for Dane was to
win one bullet game as we said the next
step is going to be he's gonna have to
withstand hikara winning a game at some
point right because the car was going to
win some games here in the bullets
he's gonna have to maintain his
confidence that he got from winning even
when when he loses some of these well
this time management is not going to cut
it he's got 15 seconds although the last
game he proved me wrong he's he's been
very very good with you know 10 or 15
seconds on his clock and he's adopted
that strategy of just going back and
forth he's not shy about that he said
all right hey Carl show me how you're
going to improve right
yep there we go Bishop E7 Bishop f80 car
is eventually going to probably play G4
or C4 or something
yeah ding has uh gotten himself 20
seconds with this type of strategy now
Bishop B4
[Laughter]
it takes on E1 now he's gonna lose A5
probably although he's clinging to it
yeah it's
now it's not that easy to win although
Hikaru breaks through oh he's just gonna
push past it
he's gonna push past it now but now has
blockaded it and it's gonna probably win
it with Knight C3 at some point
okay oh and he's allowed to C5 and now
the knight's gonna come to D4 here
really good presence of mind
now before Oh man all the black pieces
are struggling now E5 is crushing I
think
oh wait no B5 CB C6 Queen B6 maybe it's
not so simple
if I were preparing it with Queen C3
yeah and he's going to take A4 also no
this is over
probably now B5 is good
no you feel better yeah he wants to put
black in the pocket no risk right just
come around put the bishop on it he does
not want to watch this game he wants to
make sure that this is a full point Jing
is doing his best I mean he's not giving
this away easily he's getting a blockade
going now if you take everything and
take C6 he might allow a Nas to check on
A2
so Hikaru hesitating here going Bishop
A4
how is he going to break through now
it's his turn wait take say one takes me
before he blood of the beep on yeah
but now he got C6
but now he got C6 it all paid off and
it'd be five and he's gonna win that was
a huge blunder in the middle there the
car just letting ding take his beep on
he doesn't take it and now it's over
yeah just in one second but he did have
ding under five seconds I mean it's hard
like not expecting like a mistake like
that right it's hard to react in that
amount of time no but five seconds is
enough to not pre-move and react still
react to him so I think he's going to be
kicking himself once he discovers this
in any case it's back down to a
one-point lead and again Hikaru
repeating that semi-kings Indian line
this time he doesn't throw a Kings
Indian move order
last time he was doing it through a
queen's Indian move order right
last time it was like oops this time
it's like no I meant it right
no but ding is so good at breaking these
structures down he's already breaking
through on the queen side yeah let's see
how he manages to keep up the pressure
here
yeah this is a very important game
I think if your car ties the match then
the confidence the momentum completely
switches yeah yeah he's gonna have to
play B5 to stop Knight C4 I was thinking
of A4 for ding on the previous move but
he
isn't working to do this now he allows
A4 and maybe think we'll have a
sacrifice on B5
there's a common sack on B5 in these
positions and there it is there it is
gotta do it and he's gonna mop up
Black's entire Queen side he's gonna
have three connected passers oh doesn't
want that one
he's not threatening to take either of
hikaru's pieces no but he's avoiding a
block hating move Bishop C6 from Hikaru
and Rook C1 is coming and then he is
going to be threatening stuff takes and
Bishop B5 looks really good and then
Knight C4
takes B5 and Knight C4 I mean I feel
like he's also the play chance to take
on A4 and then push B5 and
on the bishop like that
uh
yep I like that approach
maybe some of his Advantage evaporates
but now he has a risk-free position
Knight D6 is an idea oh
where does Mike Go
oh yeah the Rooks got a job oh there's a
back rank mate though it's six yeah
there is a back ring made but now 97 is
a huge 30 car it was hanging by a thread
here
H4 didn't create creates Luft and style
Knight F6 is a nice move getting the
night out of the crosshairs of The Rook
yeah
E4 needs to be covered 15 seconds to get
out of the way of the a pawn
Hikaru pulled this one out in a very
very concerning position
if ding wins this it's possible he's up
by two again with 18 minutes remaining
Queen G40 Carl this is what he does he
creates counter play against his
opponent's king and then time pressure
at night age five and he's gonna start
surrounding White's King all of a sudden
yeah ding is pushing his Pawn all right
can I get to A7 it can't get there fast
enough
I Hikaru cooking up his own counter Play
Bishop H6 uh oh
it's gonna be problems for white ding
might have to go King F2 yeah and then
Queen H4 will come Hikaru is completely
in control here
does he dare go to D3 he dies but
actually black doesn't have a check on
the eight yeah he's got the Knight
covering it Queen F4 was a mistake your
car underestimating that move now ding
as his pawn and A7 yeah but can he go
back to E3
now now he wants to Rook B8 but can he
Dodge King F2 and Rook B8 is coming he's
gonna make a second Queen
he can make a queen right now yeah and
win the game immediately you should just
make a queen here
takes on f8 Queen B4
oh
that is like that Jagger
oh my goodness and ding is back up by
two
just uh Exquisite wow technical effort
walking his King out of what seemed to
be at the very least a Perpetual check
was under that impression as well we've
got a match and a bullet match and I
don't know who's gonna win the match so
right it is impossible to say yeah so
it's actually a question mark in the
player's heads here and for the first
time in his in definitely this season
hikara was he's in serious danger of
losing and he's in a position where he
really can't afford to lose this game
I mean when you get down by three with
15 minutes left we've seen those kinds
of comebacks but they become
exponentially more difficult yeah I like
what he's doing here love what he's
doing actually G4 he's not castling he's
leaving the king side for an attack
foreign
Bishop D4 you can't really take that and
open the e-file yeah
so the original match plan is sort of
like out the window now for it like he's
he's he's
improvising here now I think whitakara
was expecting is you know he would be up
by one or by two and then he just sort
of ambled through the bullet
he was not expecting to be down by two
and you can see him playing much sharper
openings
he's succeeding with white but so far
he's been really struggling with black
even in the bullet yeah and I don't like
this position here at all with the
random Pawn on G4 I would slam Yeah by
G2 if I were allowed no I kind of do I
like the fact that he's got the two
Bishops and I think it's very hard to
handle a center like this now he's gonna
put the Knight on D4
and I feel like this is the kind of
position he wants you know he wants to
get into
he has tons of threats I think he's
going to win this game
okay oh yeah F7 suddenly being lasered
if the Rook defends it there's Bishop D6
coming
for the moment yeah he needs the queen
on D2 defended to go for Bishop D6 but
he when he's comfortable you know he's
he has the initiative it's he's not
letting this one go Rook D4
reacts
one of both feels that one didn't bleed
some clock here if he wants to with 15
minutes left I mean that's plenty of
time you can't really play the clock at
this point no no all he needs to do is
like recover for next game here because
I saw that one like hit him he was just
yeah boom
that's what make partially what makes
him so dangerous and bullet is he sees
these with a hundred percent and
everything he sees them with 100
accuracy ending yeah he can sit for
another 20 seconds I think that's what
that's what he's gonna do
Hikaru pre-moving his way into mate and
dang was going to sit this one out which
was totally valid as we as we often
discuss
this is part of the strategy he's up by
one he wants as little time on the match
clock as possible because then he knows
he scores one win that could end the
match and anything can happen in any one
individual game
yeah
yeah and and taking that time also gives
him a chance to to recover from from the
game so now we have to see how he how he
handles this one
yeah he mentally resets and and it's
actually a very smart strategy very
smart strategy takes some deep breaths
okay put this game behind you he has his
skin on F1 already he could castle by
hand with G3 King G2 which is what he's
gonna do yeah and another one of these
structures which has been not very kind
to Hikaru one should say even in the
bullet yeah this time with the bishop on
E7 which certainly doesn't like improve
it or anything nope the bishop is on E7
rather than G7 I guess the one way it
does maybe improve is that in the event
of a trade on on C6 the bishop would
have guarded the d-pawn no now I love
what Hikaru has B5 B4 oh yeah this is
about as good as these positions get
which is not that good but still
yeah I think that Bishop A6 was a was a
nice spot
um seeing that coming in ig4 he's gonna
Force thing to give up his Bishop no
this is looking great for Hikaru yeah
now let's see what happens can he
equalize the match score or will ding
strike again
F5 is mighty tempting I know I was
thinking that Bishop was stopping at
five are you sure that you want to move
it
Bishop C8 I think we all know what a car
is preparing there it is yeah and he's
got 57 seconds this one is I wouldn't
say in the toilet for ding but
it's not looking good no no it's it's
not his position's a little bit raggedy
here and facing the bishop pair in H5
there will be H3 so it's there's no
nothing decisive just yet
yeah Knight F6 hicaro brings the Knight
back now I would try I would take that
in a heartbeat just a technical move he
probably wants to no he doesn't want GF
okay oh
aggressive intentions
very aggressive although ding defending
the H file and anchoring creating an
anchor point for his Knight on G5 wow
looks like he wants to play Knight G5
himself there with the way he's
positioning those Brooks and now he
plays Bishop C4 and really like that
move
while King AKA was threatening Queen
takes D5 I think
oh okay oh yeah that pawn was hanging I
didn't notice that it hadn't been before
so it was sort of like a
thing pushing the queen away yeah but
now there's no Knight G5 so he's oh no
cars
I was aiming at G4
this is a manka s position for for y
there's so many things that could fall
apart here
yeah and he keeps Hikaru keeps getting
him to push his spawns yeah yeah
11 minutes just don't blink
what's the Breakthrough though Rook H6
to keep H7 you see a car just refusing
to make any like commitments with the
pawn structure well I think I think it
would make sense for hikara here to just
secure the draw and you know he's been
doing so well with white there's time
plenty of time in the match
but let's see I mean this could turn for
in a for you know for either side yeah
it's hard to say with opposite colored
Bishops as long as there's some pieces
on the board these attacks will just
whip up
the acara was going for a G6 and ding
maybe should have taken now he opens the
G phone Black's gonna benefit from that
although Jake's gonna get his Rook to
see two real fast
yeah like immediately oh but now A4
comes striking on the other side oh this
is falling apart completely for white
yeah yeah this and now with the other
side getting slides from both sides yeah
he is you can just see it in the way
Hikaru is moving in network A7 one move
on one side
Rook takes a B1 on Queen G2
Rook B1 road takes B1 and queen G2 or
immediately oh
is going to tie the match
and it's all time he didn't need any of
his 20 seconds to calculate that nope
Queen G2 both Rooks boom boom ding with
one last attempt at a perpetual
a car is gonna find a way Queen a queen
G8 even yikes
man once he had his opportunities like
he just knew everything you have to do
A4 Rook G8 Rook A8 Rook A2 Queen G2 oh
man I would think that you guys gonna
win this game if he wins the next game I
think he wins the match but ding has to
find it in himself to to turn the tables
with black
that's the only way because the car is
about to take off you know he wins this
game and then there will only be two
more chances and I just don't see him
giving up if he gets a lead I don't seem
giving it up Bishop F4 was made by the
way yeah what's with this weird King
march like down a rook and then like
still sort of playing this relatively
close it's still completely lost but
amazing
he's taking more time off the clock
although I don't know who that favors
and I think okay he's gonna oh it's not
gonna flag yet
but like Caro could have like taken the
queen or Checkmate yeah
maybe they're both just uh you know
setting the stage for a photo finish
uh-huh they're just like letting it come
down to the last second or something
well it's come down to the last nine and
a half minutes
that's how long remains in the match the
score is tied at 12 a piece here we go
Nakamura with another Ry Lopez I think
the switch to E4 has been a very smart
one Hikaru has gotten great positions in
in these Ry Lopez's
and dang with an archangel this time
wow
the match is as exciting as the previous
semi-final Donya amazing and it is
yeah and that one it came down to the
wire Wesley pulled away at the very end
yeah let's see who pulls away here
hikara with another nice position out of
the opening and I I really not sure I
like the way ding is handling these
although this is okay I'm surprised the
car took with a plot on D5
now I think black has that five black as
Knight of four this is fine for black
this is totally fine for me yeah he
grabs space but actually black
neutralizes it easily with the very same
move guitar we used yeah this is this is
a little bit shoddy for White Queen
Knight F4 could come at some point
Bishop G4 yeah black Scott kingside play
that's for sure white does have the a
file though so no don't fall asleep on
that right and black has to time it
right because if Black Goes Knight F4
they always have to look at D4 for white
in response oh yeah that's true
undermining the Knight Queen H4 so ding
slides into the screen the car offering
a queen trade I wouldn't take it yeah
but definitely black wants to keep the
Queens on the board no doubt about it
Matt F4
is a big threat now because 92 is gonna
bother white yeah Knight F4 is getting
better sidestepping it
so far nothing impossible to say this is
such a tense position right I'm
surprised the ding hasn't lifted The
Rook yeah
this is like a big Pro yeah exactly he
has to wait for you to say it and then
he's got to do it yeah in the meantime
he keeps assembling pieces on the king
side Rook G6 the other Rook could come
to f8 Hikaru
lunging forward with G4 now Knight E4
Rook takes G4 Rook takes G4 that's a
winning end game for Mike he's gonna win
two blondes yeah oh my goodness this is
this is more but car is in Mortal danger
in this game Bishop takes H3 well ding
followed your advice and won the game
yeah well I don't know if he's won yet
though 26 seconds the car is going to
find a way to make this complicated
let's see I don't see how Rook G4 Rook
G2 I mean everything's falling here
Ting just has to play fast he's down in
20 seconds maybe bishop G2 was winning
this is really good too because now if
the king ever crosses like F2 you just
attack The Rook with your bishop and
it's Annie Carter resigns he he feels
that he has no chances in this game six
minutes 50. one point lead for ding he
wins a game with black can you believe
that yeah and I think we're already
seeing sort of a semi-strategic
resignation by Hikaru there just to get
the next game going like based on Match
clock
if there weren't like a match clock
issue like he still has some chances
there he just oh yeah
and what he feels is that you know he
doesn't want a situation where if he
loses this game he wants to guarantee
himself another chance so if he loses
this game and he's got there's five
minutes left in the match clock you
could play two more games and again if
the game starts and there's two seconds
left on the match clock the game counts
yeah okay so we have another one of
these closed positions ding this time
castling with Queen side which I really
like
yeah he just gave his car with totally
different strategic flavor no but this
is like bad for like C5 is coming and
black might get checkmated on the
Queen's head Queen before yeah this is
right up Dean's Valley Queen A4 it's a
very nice move in response
yeah Knight E7 car finding a way to get
his pieces out no I yeah black now looks
a lot better than he did like three
moves ago
yeah I want another Rook lift but
I don't see it yet so see you soon in
the middle he's gonna try to blast
through the queen side here wow
what if BC and D5 no King A8 car is
sidestepping
the trouble
five and a half remaining in the match
dealing with 25 seconds he takes the
night
this looks like it could go either way
I see size six Pawn looks like it's
already gone
it is the only thing in the White's
favorite here is Black's King is still
very very unsafe but
yeah this is looking really oh F4 is a
nice move because E4 there will be
Knight takes E4 oh he needed that and if
Knight G6 the Knight D5 so Hikaru
finding a very nice response Rook gd8
fantastic move oh my goodness it really
is
after him
wow six defending everything is finding
the moves that like still make it
controversial oh yeah no and black is
probably has the upper hand here up upon
but ding is playing this so well
to keep this close four and a half
remaining now Hikaru clinging to his
extra Pawn can he will go Queen C5 can
he find counter play against Black's
king that's gonna be the question here
Queen C6 Takara trying to stabilize
A4 getting the Knight to C5
whoops that did not happen oh there's
Queen F3 and you step off he's trying to
get his rotate he wants Checkmate yeah
you carved down to 20 seconds himself
yeah oh my goodness he's gonna be
playing Rook A3 pretty soon and queen A6
yeah and this might be close to winning
Rook D3 Queen G80 can take in and go 96.
oh oh he goes ring T1 he doesn't see
Knight A6 but he finds a different thing
he's just going so fast no he had to go
96 that was winning in the spot he still
has a huge attack can he convert it
three and a half left in the match he
pushes his ape on up the wood black is
still in huge trouble bringing it all
the way up to A6 take away the squares
no training Rook D40 car can try to
activate himself
oh I love Woody Carr just did there got
the D file now he's got a position from
which we can try to trade Queens
seven oh my goodness hey card does not
snap up the queen trade but thanks for
four seconds for a long time he's got
five seconds 196 you might see a
repetition of moves with Knight B5 I
think ding has to go for it
Hikaru deciding I think your car is
going to repeat
it
before 90 seconds what a gamble Knight
F7 ding has to play ding cannot allow
94.
Roxy one second now he car is going to
play an id4 no dick doesn't allow it
what a crazy idea both sides going after
each other's quants one second for ding
the car's gonna trade Rooks what's going
on here take me four no no he cars got
to be like more or less lost here yeah
but it's A5 he's got the a pawn I think
he's in a practical
this is a draw
okay in fact Dave yes the thing has to
push those tons of Fizz pretty damn
pretty darn fast because the car is
going to get some chances soon
uh oh Knight D5 now ding is struggling
here
dicaro has a chance here to win this oh
yeah Knight E3 is a great move back to
C4
ding wants to give his Pawn away for
Empire's night two minutes remaining the
next one might be the last
uh yay one second
how is Hikaru even pushing here does it
Rob our repetition oh unbelievable that
being held that if ding holds this one
you might win the match two minutes
remaining this is likely to be the last
game oh my goodness the car with the
white pieces though he's played very
well on the bullet with white he needs
to win just a force
over talk out
and for ding if ding feels that he's
losing bleeding out the clock and
forcing a tiebreaker might be the way to
go
yeah oh my goodness can Hikaru win on
demand to tie the match ding is doing
well in the opening so far very solid
here comes sicaro with G4 again as in
the last game
okay I like this approach in a bullet
game this Knight G3 plan is a simple
plan and it's an attacking plan okay
ding getting his pieces to the center
okay D it is likely coming yeah holy
smokes everybody's in the chat G5 the
car going full steam ahead opening up
like King side
rookie six defending the night Hikaru
playing King G2 Knights coming to F5
rook's coming to G1 I'm gonna G1
things trying to lift his rook and get
it to G6 somehow in the way of that
Bishop might have five looks really nice
here yeah the car's position looks great
yeah that wasn't what they wanted that
Knight F5 on Bishop E7 Knight H5 looks
good here ding trying to discharge the
tension 58 seconds left yeah in the
match this is raid on e4 and play Queen
D3 to get out of the middle game but
look at how danger retooled his pieces
and got his King relatively say there he
does exactly what you said yeah
checkmate's the queen Hikaru is not
better in the same game he has to win an
equal end game to avoid losing the SEC
semi-final ding has 30 seconds so
hikaru's got the full minute on his
clock he's got 30 seconds to the good
yeah that's because the car wants to
keep open the option of maybe even
playing another game right indeed
literally uses zero seconds but very
very smart by Hikaru he realizes yeah
the end game is equal but he has a
minute ding with 20 seconds he's running
his H1 up the board he still wants to
weaken black skin ding with 15 seconds
on the clock wow ding has really slowed
down here suddenly he slowed down and I
don't see him holding this if he's he
has to be very precise hikara wants
Knight F5 in this position yeah
then getting his Bishop to a good Square
he carry getting his Knight to effort
this is officially going to be the last
game if if your car wins this they go to
overtime yeah if dangerous he wins the
match it's over ding would go to the
finals
but this is very concerning for black
now Dink and start Hikaru can start
doubling on the G5 he's got 50 seconds
to play this end game yeah
oh my goodness how do you use the 50
seconds in a situation like this Well
everybody's holding their breakfast
gotta be very careful not to repeat it
three times by accident yeah yeah
they don't play Knight H4 here I think
that last end game the night end game
was drawn by repetition by accident like
okay it's one thing yeah it definitely
was and Hikaru taking no chances you're
doubling now on the H file that Bishop
on H6 is so vulnerable how is they gonna
hold everything together five seconds
he's got no time this is he's got
five seconds he's gonna play instantly
in exchange here whoa Bishop C1 it was a
mouse now slip he was going to D2 oh it
was going to D2 but it was still bad
Rook H7 check would have been terrible
yeah oh my goodness Hikaru saves the
match with a win in the last game game
and we're going to overtime we're going
to the tie breaker it'll be four one
plus one games
oh my goodness and ding is sitting back
and he can't believe it
and icaro wins the one of the clutchest
games of his Online Career but now he's
got to follow it up with a dominating
performance in the tiebreaker David wow
my gosh it's the mouse that is fantastic
what he's just done uh yeah and we need
to figure out what the we need to
refresh everyone's uh knowledge of the
tie break format right since that's
what's about to come up on basically
they're gonna play a four-game match of
one plus that's it four one plus one
match and the you know and if that it
ends in a tie then then they're going to
Armageddon but again
I haven't had any Armageddon yet we have
had one playoff this is our second one
oh and we got another
Queen's Gambit declined seeing this line
okay in this line a couple times yeah
ding has done well in these positions
behind him I think he's got a very good
score yeah just in this particular well
he's he's been playing these for for
many years actually he's got a great
handle on the ideas
Hikaru seems to be the one seems to be
the aggressor here as he plays Knight E4
offering a trade and he's going to get
the other Knight to D5 and in the past
things always avoided the trade but here
with the Rook on A3 I didn't see any way
not to make the trade yeah he was
basically
forced into it and I like the idea for
Hikaru of just getting the Knight to D5
this seems easier to play for black yeah
and ding has to be careful not to just
collapse right just lose the first game
and then before you know it you're
facing a deficit he has to in my eyes he
has to win this game yeah but he's not
looking something right now immediately
right here in this position before
Knight f65 comes in the Hikaru puts a
knight on D5 and you've got a 30 second
deficit again you're not you're not
holding that
I mean he's really he's thinking hard I
mean it's like a deep deep think Bishop
back to G3 is not a good sign it just
hasn't found anything convincing and
he's burned 30 seconds to try to try and
find it yeah
adopting a completely defensive posture
and again you don't even have the time
advantage to show for it yeah B5 looks
good here just shutting the Knight down
yep Rook a four Rook a and I mean
Black's play is so easy
wow fantastic position for a car right
here
Knight C3 I mean ding is still very
solid of course yeah but he really just
caught ding out with Rook a 394 there
and yeah exactly what he wants
or hanging
yeah that before Pawn is the concerning
Pond for white if you lose that pawn you
lose the game
hikara might play a five at some point
so take his eyes take his mind off the
the ephon
okay 19 seconds for ding to hold on to
this one which is not like looking good
at all yeah but I mean if you can get
the Rooks traded I think you'll be okay
Hikaru can't really get the bishop in
any way to attack the the bee Pawn right
I which is I guess I'm hurting Queen A2
here to trade Queens go to The Rook
ending play E5 and bring the king to C4
yeah that's what he's doing and he's
definitely gonna play five I love that
idea yeah and he's not letting this
opportunity slip he's gonna try
everything he can ding trying to get his
own King closer to the to the queen side
and here comes the car was king at five
G4
no the ding is not saving this game
there's no way
threatened by H4
and then the king's gonna come to G4 H4
King H5 King G4
and then H3 as a pawn sack and the King
goes to F3 or something yep exactly
exactly
you even have time to to take on issue
car choosing to trade the Bishops
okay ding declining that
H3 would have been very strong right in
that position
I'm here
C3
Bishop takes E3 is very strong I think
yeah
and Dane is going to lose
oh that was just a squish man just a
squish that's how you use an open file
folks for anybody wondering that Ding
specializes in just completely outplayed
and this is the first time in a while
that ikaro has been ahead he must be
feeling real good right now and digging
with a black pieces he's essentially a
must-man territory I mean you can lose
this game and win the next two but
that's let's be real that's not going to
happen if your car wins yeah I mean
today you know there's like a one yeah
no for sure anything is possible one of
these days things been great but he did
have trouble you know G4 and ig3 he did
have trouble in the last game in this
line here and the game before that a
couple games in a row so he's gonna have
to really prove his setup here for black
for sure and this time Hikaru plays it
without G4
which ended up being pretty weakening in
the last couple of games so he's making
some changes and that Knight H2 move is
often to get the Knight to G4 which is a
pretty typical idea in these positions
and let's see how this unfolds but but
26 was a slick move to prevent it
because the B3 Pawn had to be defended
and then white lost control over G4
right
and dingeting is Knight to C5 this is
not looking great when you have to play
Rook A3 that's a bad sign H5 and G6 is
always possible in these positions
kicking the night away
yeah not to mention D3 Queen D3 Bishop
A3 Queen takes B3 just like the fact
that you have to watch out for every one
of those transitions every move
because like it might just be bad for
you for sure you have a lot of a lot of
stuff that you need to attend to but
ding is the one down to 20 seconds first
yeah and Here Comes The Rook to B6 okay
B6
that B3 Pawn is not very healthy I guess
Knight D2 is possible but then D takes
C3 would lose the D3 Pawn so first
hecarly trades on D4 maybe he'll go
Bishop F4 going for active counter play
ding
parking his night on B4 his Knights are
phenomenal but Knight takes D3 is pawns
are also hanging on C7 and D4 I would
just snap that pawn on D3 and then play
Queen takes C4
wow so much stuff is hanging here and 15
seconds to figure it all out
takes D6 okay d8 queen of five massive
liquidation you cannot take on D4 oh B4
is a nasty move opening an attack
against the Knight oh and then ding has
to move his Queen to D5 I think you
gotta play Queen D5 counter attack the
bishop right finds it and guard can pick
up D4 as well oh how did he get out of
that yeah when that came out with only
one extra Pawn for ding I was feeling an
escape
doesn't even have she doesn't even have
the pawn to show for this is likely that
in a drawing that's completely fine for
Hikaru yeah
he's gonna play this though for us five
seconds any you know anything is
possible yeah that's a stressful move
yeah
ding goes for a Quincy too yeah this is
very similar to the move that hikara won
with last game yeah
saving it afterwards no this is the dead
I just don't see this even being
interesting because how is he gonna
create any chances
I mean marginally better for the bishop
because the board is kind of open but
White's going to put the pawn on B3 and
you're never going to touch it right
just nothing we might see a draw
agreement they might also play this out
for a while
yeah there's no there's no match clock
now it's just four games so the time
spent doesn't matter at all yeah I think
GeForce is slightly risky for white
yeah it opens a little bit of space
yeah that's what ding is trying to do
he's trying to restrict the Knight
although Knight C3 might be possible
here I think Knight D6
oh ding has to be careful now oh my God
he might lose this oh my
Bishop c3927 King F4 Knight C7 now he's
gonna save it after all my goodness that
was close oh my God
he was down a 0.1 seconds
yeah wait a second it's still not our
car was gonna try to milk this until
yeah
okay ding saves the game yeah big big
save right there at the end a big save
for Hikaru and two more games left ding
does not look at all unfamiliar with
bullet let's say that like yeah he looks
like a 2800 player who can also play
2800 at bullet
oh my goodness
okay
um well we have another one of these
Queens Gambit decline positions
and can ding improve this time has he
got Bishop C2 before I don't think so
no the bishop has been traded every game
so every time yeah so yeah so he keeps
the bishop this time black again because
the Rook A3 and the car is doing the
same thing and it worked last game yeah
and I think he's he has a great position
here Queen A5 is a threat I mean I'm
just not impressed that these positions
in the context of a bullet bullet game
yeah Bishop Diego
that's a big threat and if Hikaru wins
this game he wins the match uh he gets
two and a half before the last this
keeps pushing and and what what's the
plan even after Bishop Bishop takes H6 I
think I think the point for dinghy if
black moves the Knight is to take Bishop
H6 here looks pretty oh my goodness
goodness
takes F6 I think he's trying to do
something similar
what is going on here Hikaru is
seriously considering not even to Queen
C1 and then I guess fg7 or Bishop takes
H6 and going for mate this position is
crazy he has to play Bishop H6 here that
he just has to
he has to play it I don't understand
why even the hesitation yes now the next
movie Bishop G7 not oh this is five this
is dreadful for black man maybe Knight
back to E8 in order to open a pathway
yeah between blacks queen and the g Pawn
maybe you can try to push the F Pawn 98
you could still pursue G7 you could
still consider bishop and then the
Knight swoops into G5 this might be
winning today we might be going out of
the wire again this is an amazing
15 seconds he might go Knight E4 and he
does go 98. I agree anyway Bishop G7
Knight G7 Queen H6 and Knight G5 I say
just do it no ding he's done that way
too many times this match nobody's
winning Bishop C3 Bishop H7 Bishop C3
Bishop H7 oh my goodness so much tactics
is being missed here I am shocked yeah
Bishop takes G7 he has to see Bishop G7
Queen H6 and Knight G5 that is and he
does and kudos to ding he saw it when he
played Bishop D2 he's saying I'm
repeating that position oh he did take
on G7 oh my God he found the whole it's
mate Queen H7 yeah where's the mate or
Rook takes C6 maybe Knight takes C6
Rook B8 you wanna move amazing Queen H7
queen h8 queen takes V8 amazing it's
like what Hikaru did with Rook 81. we're
down to the wire again this is the last
game of the tie break overtime game four
of four the match is tied ding with the
black pieces again will we see Deja Vu
will Hikaru win this one as well can
dink turn his fortune oh my goodness
this is this is this is probably the
most amazing match I've I've ever seen
yep in the SEC and that's saying a lot
because there's been some amazing
matches okay we have a Ry Lopez
but we've seen the structure once before
David yeah we saw this exactly this is a
line This is Theory the bishop of six
yeah they're repeating the entire game
now ding was in great shape there but he
lost that game if I remember correctly
yes although there were a lot of
turnarounds this time breakthrough on
the queen side
this is new Queen B6 check is new
how is he gonna follow this up
59 seconds a car over a minute yeah of
course watch this game end in a draw got
Armageddon
taking the first long think of the game
what is he gonna do he's down to 40
seconds This is highly concerning
already he's down 20 seconds plays A5
and let's see if that thing pays off oh
my goodness
Knight C6 now can you go Queen F2 that's
the square I'm looking at
Knight C5 and Knight B3 is still very
much dangerous Knight C5 would also
threaten Knight D3 if white takes with
the queen yeah so Hikaru taking with a
knight well that's oh is this is not
coming to D3 in case of Queen F2 yeah so
ding's got to take the file first and I
guess zikaru can still go Knight to
three but now Knight C5 looks good the
evil bar creeping in Black's favor
it's showing a big Advantage Queen A6
also looks good just to freeze White's
pieces completely ding down to 24
seconds he's gotta make him move Queen
A6 would be threatening Queen takes D3
huh that's very dirty oh you can just
see nervousness anxiety written all over
their face to see Carl's King is a
mortal danger David that night come
stage for the queen comes after you
could end up being busted really fast
icaro is in huge huge trouble in this
game he's gonna Retreat the Knight to to
not bring the queen but where would he
go because
Queen F2 oh he invites the Knight to H4
as well it should be three what a move
by Hikaru what a counter getting his
Rook out of the gate out of the gates
well he's still in bad shape though
Queen takes me two he bought us the pawn
well he had to because I mean the beat
thing was already dead but he didn't
take it yeah then going for me but I
pulled disregard for the queen side by
the players here when he takes me two
was winning pretty much on the spot yeah
Luigi won by Hikaru tucking his Queen in
ding Rook to the second still very bad
for white Rook takes B2 and it's time to
grab that pawn threatening three Bishops
not interested he wants mate yeah
nothing but mate wait why didn't you
show Bishop F4 I don't know Queen G1
Queen back to G1
Rook F3 Maybe
oh eating oh everybody's dream come true
more games no ding wants checkmate
I don't know if he does he's got 12
seconds he's got no time I don't see the
win I don't know if I agree we're going
over again and we keep going I'm going
to Armageddon unbelievable Hikaru
survives
that was amazing with Bishop E3
what a setup and actually at the end I
like ding's decision because the a pawn
was hurtling down the board black could
lose that really easily too so I
wouldn't trust the eval bar there
um now let's refresh everybody including
ourselves on what the Armageddon format
is because I'm right this is so unlikely
that I don't even really read into it
there's a single Armageddon game
now we're getting confirmation on the
time control of that game I would
imagine it's five to four but don't
quote me on that we're gonna get
confirmation
momentarily here right
again nobody expects this to happen so
you got to open the rule book you know
all right
if it's like a Blitz game instead of a
bullet game that's a weird like sort of
like Whiplash for the players to like
have just played bullets for you know 50
minutes and then suddenly go back to a
Blitz game
and the the basic premise of the
Armageddon is that white has to win if
the game is in a draw then the player
playing Black wins the match right and
black starts with the time deficit now
the size of this deficit is yeah it is
five plus four Hikaru is choosing the
color I believe it's because he has the
higher rating going in okay and he is
choosing the color and ballpark Donya
how many dollars is this one game worth
the match and then I don't know how much
goes to the loser though
like I or is it by percentage there's
going to be 3 000 each from this
semi-final right so it's 6 000 for the
winner plus whatever your odds are at a
20 000 total pot in the finals exactly
a lot of finals it's a sixteen thousand
dollar game a lot of money is on the
line in this one game it's five foot so
I actually really like the fact that the
Armageddon that the match isn't decided
by a bullet game because matches like
these deserve to be decided by a sort of
serious longer game I'm very curious to
see what side Hikaru has chosen I would
imagine that he's chosen black given
that to him a time deficit isn't such a
big deal but the onus of winning the
game is is a huge one I always feel like
black is on the better side of an
Armageddon and there we go but they got
to reset the time so there we go four
minutes the thing has five yeah and
certainly in this match black has has
done very well so oh my God buckle your
seat belts now we're gonna have a much
slower opening here let's not expect
anybody to Blitz out any moves there's
no increment though there is no
increment which means flagging is very
much on the table David
did ding play 1c4 for the first time in
this match here I'm pretty sure I think
he did and he just decides to start with
a clean slate yeah we have a Mainline
English where Hikaru played E5 kind of a
reverse Sicilian Vibes yeah hard to give
an evaluation yet I mean so this is all
very normal Knight coming to C5
yeah white is a little bit more
comfortable in these positions I've
always felt but oh yeah I love playing
this opening as white
um but hey Carlos looking at Bishop H3
so I wonder if ding wants to play Rook
F2 D1 or something like that before
before throwing Knight C5 in order to
dodge the trade with Bishop H1
yeah well he's doing it a different way
distracting black first and I think
after he takes D4 he's gonna kind of
solve two problems with one move here
playing rook fd1 and hitting that pawn
but so Hikaru wants to trade on D4 with
the Knight first before I now slips F5
but it can actually be a serious Canada
giving the pawn back but on his own
terms okay I don't like this position
for black I mean ding has his Rook now
on the D file looks like a car was like
psyching himself up as we as as we get
into the heat of this game
well but black black kind of wants
Bishop F5 in some of these positions
although it can be met with Knight H4
Cara bringing his pieces back adopting a
more defensive posture
something oh Dingman think of fork and
blundered an exchange
can't believe it
but here's the bright thing the good
thing for ding is that he might not be
worse here David he might actually still
be in very good shape his positions he
was talking amazingly good before that
now it's looking good now it's still
looking good I think white is still in
good shape here but the psychological
effect of he blunder that for sure you
could see it on his face guess what he's
threatening B7 he wants to take the
bishop can Hikaru find his way out of
the complications here two minutes and
53 seconds
the second Pawn would be a big deal the
queen Escape season now though but at
five forcing a trade of Bishops that's
gonna take the teeth out of White's
initiative by a big margin oh yeah and
those Knights are disc coordinated they
were sitting together just dominating
that sixth rank pieces were just
yeah Knight D2 I wanted to propose night
takes F5 but I forgot the Knight on D5
was night on B6 was defending D5
okay all right two pawns for the
exchange this is a playable position
playable position yeah but I think very
much defanged one of the things about
those two nights in the center was that
there were a lot of different scenarios
where Dane could have come out with the
bishop pair which I think would have
made it like a lot more fun for white to
play with the bishop pair one down in
exchange it would be funny if he had
blundered a second exchange also on B4
on the same square this time thing
doesn't blunder it he plays Bishop A3
now he's preserved the time Advantage
which is pretty impressive I would take
with a rook here and try to go Knight E5
yeah yeah I would definitely take with a
rook here yep he's better again
Queen D3 maybe just bring the queen back
yep consolidating minute up on the clock
wants to avoid Rook d8 trading off his
material the Knight on B6 has found
itself on a very very unfortunate Square
now yep well that's and and he actually
might be traded because Dane might want
to get his Rook to the seventh rank or
you could play B4 and solidify the
bishop in either case white is better
but oh before I might give up eight two
I don't know if that's necessary
yeah he didn't really have a plan when
he played Bishop C5 it looks like yeah
kind of a definite move there by ding
who I think is trying to keep a pretty
significant Time advance she knows that
he's gonna get flagged if they get to a
Time scramble
Rook cd80 car doing a good job keeping
things stable here and pushing his Queen
Side Pawn up trying to add to the
pressure uh that's why he was moving the
bishop off A3 he wanted to
rookie floor is a nice move you can't
take it because you're going to lose the
bishop at the end of the line
right Bishop C back to C5 and we're
gonna see a trade of Brooks which
generally speaking is fine for black
here
yeah I know I think generally speaking
it's an improvement for black to get rid
of whites only Rook
so but the a pawn that's that's like a
big Target for white right now that
Bishop is quite a good deal yeah Knight
okay so then going A5 yeah he is trying
to go for that pawn I think he wants to
play Queen A6 yeah but Hikaru has some
way does hikara have some way to
neutralize this initiative because the
Evo bar is showing equality I don't see
it off the top of my head at night
before
oh Queen takes a seven takes takes a
knight C6 maybe okay and then if you
think she's gonna be five with Rook A8
wow back to D5 maybe we'll see A6 just
fixing the pawn on A7
I would highly consider that by dangan
he plays it it's too intense it's too
hard to play for he is still down a
minute on the clock and now he's got a
minute and a half with no increment ding
needs to be aware of that because this
might come down to flagging
right thing can keep a Time advantage
that's for sure and and the tension is
there for this game to like not have too
many more trades yeah even Hikaru has to
take but but Damian's not making any
progress in the meantime icaro has
centralized this thesis he's kind of
pressuring A6 and drinks time Advantage
beginning to dwindle right this is I
would give Hikaru the benefit of the
doubt here I think he's holding this
Rook C8 chasing the queen around now
he's not worse anymore
and now another queen trade offered
maybe think just takes it I don't know
Bishop A7 Knight B4 now you can finally
take on A7
yes or he couldn't because of Knight F4
check this is what he was maneuvering
for Queenie for check but then dink
defends the bishop yeah and Hikaru has
to take more time here Queen G6 is also
an interesting move Big Choice here he's
still got a minute it's not it's not
he's not out of resources here yet
Knight B5 Knight C7
take Stakes Knight B5 Ricardo has this
move Knight C7 and if Knight C6 might be
Knight C7 anyway C7 anyway yeah and dank
has to flag him here one minute on the
clock black is
obviously not worse anymore although how
do you might be five night before this
move was tricky this was really tricky
he finds it maybe four yes yes that was
seven of B6 97 and B6 and White's gonna
be a pawn up in that end game wilting
see it
real thing c97 and B6 that is his only
chance to keep the second going he has
the time but he misses it he misses it
and he collapses Rook B7 King F7 King E6
yeah oh my goodness that but Rook a five
okay the problem might be the black is
not gonna give up the E4 upon and in
that case White's not winning that game
ding overlooked it
ding missing that tactical shot which
would have given him the chances and now
he doesn't see a movie Carl might pull
this one out I don't I don't see a way
to not lose the B Pawn for nothing you
can and the evil bar is bearing that up
you can go 97 ICA but that night's not
remaining I'll say this is essentially
the match right here that would just
trap your own Knight um it'll eventually
be lost there after the king thing has
to seven I mean ding has to give up the
pawn and then move the Knight around he
car is not losing this game he's got
more time on the clock
yeah and ding sitting back basically
admitting defeat and what a painful
match for dingley ran who came so close
so many times and what an incredible
effort but at the end of the day this
honestly proves zikara's dominance maybe
more than any of the crushing matches
yeah if he can pull one a match like
this out where it seems like nothing's
going his way
that just tells you so much about his
ability and it's that's it the match is
over dig resigns and Hikaru Nakamura
wins the Armageddon against England to
make it to the SEC finals King clutch
the king of Blitz coming through yet
again David what an unbelievable match
we just saw yeah I mean just Bravo to
both of them right because I mean from
from Bing's perspective like I've never
seen anyone other than Magnus give
hickar that hard a time and From
nakamura's perspective you just won like
the toughest match of your life more or
less I mean yeah he's trying to hide a
smile but I mean very deserving winner
you know ding played so amazing he just
kept striking back when he went down in
the overtime maybe his most impressive
feat was winning a game on demand
himself
he's obviously going to be very upset we
will have the players here for an
interview we will not keep them very
long dig must be exhausted they're both
exhausted uh but we will have them for a
quick interview you're watching the
speed Chess Championship presented by
coinbase stay with us we'll be back with
the interviews in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
trip we have the players here we won't
keep them for very long first Hikaru to
you congratulations that was an
absolutely epic match uh can you share
your thoughts about the match overall
and more specifically could you share
what goes through your mind uh when
you're down by one and the clock is
fading uh what do you tell yourself in
that moment to keep yourself composed
yeah I mean I I think the main thing is
you kind of just have to keep going
believe in yourself I I had a very
similar situation actually in the the
bull speed or bull Championship whatever
whatever it was called maybe uh I want
to say it was maybe all the way back in
April when I played Ali resin it was it
was very similar where I started off
very well then he came back he took the
lead and then I think right near the end
I got it to where I had just enough time
to uh potentially Force the tiger and I
think I I actually blundered a little
trick in the final bullet game but based
on that experience is the same thing
where you just try to um you just you
just try to hang in there you try to
believe that good things will happen
um but it was obviously a very tough
match and a lot of credit was a ding for
playing for the wall
yeah dingley ding you definitely played
very very well today on and this was an
extremely close match did you expect
that the match would go down to the wire
like this were you prepared to play like
a tie break
of course I didn't did not prefer topic
but I thought the game will be closer
than
than the other thoughts since I'm
totally believe my my streams although
he's a favorite but I have the chance to
actually World Championships
so today's game was very tense
yeah I I did not know that it was the
last game I fight George and I will win
the match I did not know after I lost
the black crisis I know that the fabric
yeah it's
hurt a little bit but
I have so many trends
here and there and I
I think I had more better positions
there
but he he defend well and he sometimes
he played very very quickly
uh in a very complicated position yeah
that's his experience
and in the end he yeah he learned better
I'm a great employer
well hey Carol uh they mentioned getting
good positions I did seem like you were
getting some dubious positions out of
the opening with wide in the five-minute
portion at some point you switch to 184
was that uh a planned change or was that
precipitated by not having positions
that you were satisfied with early in
the match yeah I mean it's funny I I
think I actually I tilted at two moments
kind of the first one is very funny
because I think I was up uh maybe it's
like one and a half half I think it was
the third or fourth game when I should
have won this game to take a two-game
lead that was the first moment and there
was also this next moment I know it was
five one or three more I was up by a
game but I just blitzed every move and
lost in like 25 moves with white um and
after that it just I mean it wasn't
wasn't my match at all
um so I I feel that I kind of just
tilted and um I I was just trying to
play too fast I didn't feel any rhythm I
was just trying to play too fast and I
mean I got away with it for the most
part but it wasn't it wasn't pretty
yeah it was yeah and ding I have one
question for you on beyond the speed
chess championships I'm just curious
what uh what chess event do you most
enjoy playing between you know different
kinds of tournaments speeds is there any
tournament that you enjoy playing in the
most
I would like to say I enjoy playing
online
okay yeah
yeah so something like this is is even
more fun traveling to OTB tournaments
now yes it's more relaxed and
and more games and more chance
yeah okay cool well final question to
you Hikari you're playing Wesley in the
final it's become one of the classic
rivalries in American chess I know a lot
of people are looking forward to that
match any thoughts about Wesley as an
opponent and about the match overall
um I mean I don't know I have to say out
of all speed test Championship matches
uh I mean I know the score was close but
I thought that this match was the
hardest match I played and that includes
uh the match that I lost to Magnus by
the way uh I mean obviously Dane
couldn't converted quite quite to the
same degree as Magnus did but I know
after after the match today I kind of
I'm just gonna try to try to play good
chess and um and hopefully good things
happen but really today was uh was a
very epic match and it was a lot of fun
a lot of fun to play
it was a lot of fun to watch and
commentate as well so thank you dang
thank you Hikaru for an excellent match
we will let you go and take your
well-deserved rest
and good luck your car on the final
thank you
all right another one in the books we
have one SEC match remaining David this
is one that very few people are going to
forget anytime soon
yeah no I I uh it would take a very very
heavy blow to the head for me to forget
this match just now
um and uh yeah fertile ground also for
playing through some of those games
later on and thinking about them some
more uh it was just a little thrilling
and there were a lot of moments that I'd
like to go over again on my own
absolutely I think a lot of people will
I certainly will and the final is
already set it will be Hikaru Nakamura
against Wesley so it will be Sunday
December 19th that's two days from now
at 10 A.M Pacific 1 p.m Eastern Time
mark your calendars there's no excuse
not to make it it is a weekend day
whatever plans you had with your family
will be canceled cargo against Wesley
what a classic matchup and what a
classic final it's going to be
and that means it is time to wrap up
today's coverage David this was so epic
and it was a pleasure to commentate with
you
what what a four hours yeah
four hours I want to say thank you Dania
but also just I mean thank you to Hikaru
and ding because that was just
phenomenal to see that
it absolutely was and thank you as well
too the chat we had obviously thousands
of thousands of people of very active
chat as the as the match went on down to
the wire and thank you to our excellent
production team for another Flawless
broadcast and of course the coinbase for
sponsoring the speed Chess Championship
we will see you on Sunday for the SEC
final we wish everybody a great Friday
and a great start to the weekend have a
good one you are watching the speed
Chess Championship presented by coinbase
we will see you on Sunday goodbye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]